bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille tabata sauvage est docteur
en astrophysique et fondatrice de
l'association spacebus france
bonjour tabata bon genre bon ça va ça
wright a très bien est ce que tu peux
commencer par te présenter un petit peu
en temps dans ton parcours scolaire et
professionnel
oui alors moi en fait
mais j'ai fait une licence de physique
fondamentale à l'upm c'est après mon bac
scientifique et ensuite un master
d'astrophysique à l'observatoire de
paris
et puis suivi de la thèse en
astrophysique pareil aussi à
l'observateur de paris et comment tu
t'es intéressé à l'astrophysique fond ce
que tu t'es toujours dit que tu allais
finira soit officiellement alors c'est
depuis tout petit en fait je suis très
intéressé par l'astrophysique
je me posais beaucoup de questions sur
même sur la vie en général mais surtout
sur l'univers d'ailleurs mes parents
était bien embêté parce qu'ils avaient
du mal à y répondre mais est en fait ces
questions là ne se sont jamais arrêtés
donc voilà ma mère m'emmenait dans des
conférences j'ai eu pas mal de l'iut
astros en cadeau donc j'ai payé un peu
dans tout ça et j'ai cherché un peu
toutes les réponses sur le domaine qui
m'a intéressé donc et a pris en fait
quand j'ai commencé la physique au
collège en cinquième
j'ai adoré et du coup je me suis dit bon
bah c'est ça que je veux faire de la
physique et de l'astronomie et du coup
je voulais traces trop visière je pense
depuis depuis que j'ai 13 14 ans je sais
que je vais être un str physicienne ok
donc d'eads ead et avait dès le 14 15
ans comme ça tu 15 16 ans tu disais tu
veux voulait déjà faire astrophysicienne
savait plus trop de
oui c'est ça dès le bas dès que j'ai
commencé la physique donc je pense que
c'était vers 13 ans j'ai su que je
voulais être astrophysicien et après
j'ai regardé tous les cursus qui pouvait
mener à ce métier là et bien j'ai vite
compris qu'il me fallait une thèse et
pour avoir le passeport pour être
chercheuse et du coup j'avais un peu
tracé on va dire tout mon cursus sur dix
années devant moi je suis rapidement
dans quelques autres par mes autres
camarades été assez impressionné de
devoirs que j'avais déjà tout prévu je
savais que le masters je voulais faire
je savais que je voulais faire une thèse
à astro est tous avec un 16 ans tu
savais déjà que master pouvez faire ça
c'est vraiment la tête c'est un
aboutissement de dix ans de travail pas
vraiment hockey et il n'y a jamais eu
des moments de méditation ou de doute
dans ce parcours si si si beaucoup bas
même déjà pendant la fin de toute
manière on a en a plein d'obstacles a
pas assez dans n'importe quelle à
n'importe quelle étape du cursus déjà je
pense enfin je voulais être
astrophysicienne depuis que je suis
super gêne mais je ne savais pas du tout
si j'allais avoir les capacités en maths
et en physique notamment
et si j'allais pas par un truc mais
échoué à pour m'arrêter avant quoi que
je me suis dit bon ben je vais au plus
loin que je peux j'essaye de faire mon
maximum parce que c'est vrai qu'en fait
il ya un nombre limité de bourses de
thèse en fait deux
quand on a un test on gagne un salaire
et ses bourses là sur trois ans elles se
gagnent entre guillemets sur concours
donc il ya les auditions etc et voilà en
france il ya un nombre limité
franchement c'est comme partout du coup
je m'étais toujours dit il faut que ce
soit la meilleure il faut que j'ai les
meilleurs résultats possibles il faut
que voilà que j'ai au dessus de 15 etc
quand je m'étais mis une pression
de folles et après je m'étais dit bon
voilà je vais jusqu'à jusqu'où je peux
et ça j'y arrive pas gérer ge pas quoi
mais donc c'était assez stressant et il
ya un événement particulier qui ça donne
envie de faire de ce trop physique ou
s'était progressivement
très bonne question non je crois pas que
ce soit un événement particulier c'était
plus que ce que ça me fascine et en fait
quand j'étais petit je me posais
beaucoup beaucoup de questions sur ou
est ce qu'on était dans l'univers qu'est
ce que c'était des étoiles et galaxies
est ce qu'il y avait deux planètes
enfin j'avais vraiment avide d'apprendre
et et puis voilà ça m'a jamais quittée
en fait
et du coup j'ai continué dans cette voie
là mais après c'est vrai que les
rencontres aussi que j'ai faites m'ont
aidé à enfin à m'encourager dans cette
voie là du coup j'ai tout de suite vu
que je savais ce que je voulais faire
j'ai tout de suite demandé à faire des
stages dans les labos a rencontré des
astrophysiciens et les est copieux
viennent pour voir un peu leur quotidien
et savoir vraiment si ça allait me
plaire
et puis être plus proche de ce métier là
parce qu'on en entend très peu parler en
fait quand on est obligé ou au collège
et du coup c'est vrai que j'ai tout de
suite baigné là dedans j'ai fait plein
de stages facultatifs aussi pour savoir
ce qui me plaît dans l'astrophysique
puisque l'astrophysique c'est hyper
large
il ya plein de domaines dedans donc je
voulais faire un peu des stages dans
tous les domaines pour voir ce qui me
plaisait le plus c'est ce que j'allais
choisir en thèse par exemple ok + coupes
en tant que certains à résister entre
entre deux métiers complètement
différente hésité entre deux labos de
recherche déjà ok et du coup c'est quoi
le nom du masters en question que de
décider de faire je crois que c'est
astronomie astrophysique et je sais plus
c'est un non mais bon en vrai en bref
c'est astronomie
c'est le master astronomie astrophysique
de l'observatoire de paris
donc je crois qu'il est outil outils
pour l'ingénierie
ok mais du coup c'est encore assez
générale le pasteur
ouais c'est assez général va en fait on
voit tous les thèmes de l'astronomie et
les outils les méthodes ont fait des
projets sur des télescopes mais on voit
vraiment enfin tout ce qu'est stellaire
cosmologie planétologie enfin on voit
vraiment tous les domaines en fait
ok ok et du coup après tu as de quoi tu
en cédant une thèse après tout masters
c'était quoi le sujet de thèse
alors le sujet de ma thèse dit comme ça
ça va être un peu dans le dire brut brut
de décoffrage mais on va dire le titre
de ma thèse c'est formation des pseudos
bulbes et des galaxies spirales géantes
grâce à des fusions majeures de riches
en gaz
c'est le titre brut en fait pour être
plus vulgarisée on va dire que c'est
j'ai travaillé sur les parties centrales
des galaxies spirales donc ses bisous
les plus brillantes
quand on dit galaxies spirales géante en
fait c'est le type voie lactée ou
andromède
c'est à dire pas les naines quoi les
galaxies de masse intermédiaire et j'ai
travaillé sur un certain type de partie
centrale qui s'appelle les pseudos
bulbes d'accord ok parce que du coup
pour des gens qui connaissent très pas
très bien les galaxies comme il ya
plusieurs types de galaxies qui sont
rangés en fonction de leur taille alors
c'est pas en fonction de leur taille
c'est plutôt en fonction de leur
morphologie
tu vois on a les galaxies elliptiques
qui sont en fait une galaxie c'est quoi
c'est une grosse boule des toiles et
suivant sa forme alors d'étoilés de gaz
et suivant sa forme donc elle va être
soit elliptique c'est à dire un peu
ovale avec des vieilles étoiles un peu
rouge jaune
on va avoir les galaxies spirales qui l
ont un ou un disque en fait avec des
bras spiraux comme les jeux les images
qu'on voit un peu sur tout partout sur
google voilà c'est ce truc que j'ai en
tête comptant 2 way you les yeux et puis
à brens à des galaxies irrégulière donc
qui ont pas vraiment une forme qui ont
des formations des toiles un peu partout
donc sa forme d'aidé klump l'inde et des
petits des petits amas d'étoilés un peu
par ci par là
donc cela soit un peu à part
ok et après en fonction en fait de plus
la partie centrale de la galaxie spirale
est grosse plus
en fait on va voir une classification
donc on commence par les elliptique puis
à les galaxies spirales avec des gros
bulbe puis lé galaxies spirales avec les
petits bull donc c'est en fonction de la
taille du bulbe ce que j'appelle le
bulbe ses causes donc c'est là c'est
vraiment la partie centrale de la
galaxie spirale parce qu'en fait on a le
disque mais au centre on à la partie
bull qui peut être différentes formes
qui pète ferrique mais qui peut être
aussi sous la forme d'une barre par
exemple hockey puisque du coup là est ce
que moi j'ai un peu l'image d'une
galaxie qui était très apathique
mais la partie centrale de syrie que ça
ce wave c'est ça alors suivent
injustement les différents types de
bulbes le set ce bulbe cette partie
centrale va pouvoir avoir plusieurs
formes donc soit ça va être injustement
une proéminence par rapport aux disques
fin qui va être plutôt sérique ou alors
ça peut être en fait dans la continuité
du disque mince tu vois une barre qui
reste dans le disque ou alors contraire
qui est une barre mais qui est plus
épaisse ou alors ça peut être d'autres
types de structures il ya des anneaux
interne
il ya plein de choses c'est assez
complexe et tout ce qui n'est pas simple
sphérique
en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle les
pseudos bull ok d'accord
et donc dans ce test a fait quoi donc
moi en fait ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai pris des simulations de fusions de
galaxies et donc j'ai pris je prenais
base de galaxies je les faisais
fusionner et suivant les paramètres que
j'avais mis au début je regardais en
fait qu'elle était là quel était le but
lui qui était créé à la fin donc fusions
majeures ça veut dire que on va prendre
deux galaxies qui sont très similaires
un terme de masse c'est comme s'il y
avait deux voitures qui serait entré
dedans quoi c'est pas une voiture et un
papillon
donc c'est vraiment deux grosses
galaxies qui fusionnent et donc il ya
vraiment un cataclysme
alors il faut savoir que quand deux
galaxies fusionnent n'y a pas de choc
entre les étoiles
parce qu'en fait les galaxy s'est très
vite c'est un peu comme si le système
solaire donc c'est plus ça va être plus
en fait la trajectoire des étoiles qui
va être modifié et puis la formation
stellaire dans le disque de gaz qui va
qui va être bien boosté quoi ok parce
que c'est dur on y entend les collisions
comme ça entre eux
je pense qu'on peut parler de cohésion
mais ouais alors combien de temps ça
dure bah moi ma simulation c'était sur
12 milliards d'années donc à peu près
l'âge de l'univers c'est à dire ça a
commencé il ya 12 milliards d'années et
ça et la simulation se terminer au jour
d'aujourd'hui
après la fusion à proprement dit je dis
pas de bêtises je pense qu'elle était
sûre sur 3 4 milliards d'années
ok mais après on peut imaginer plein de
choses toute manière ça sera forcément
sur minimum 1 ou 2 milliards d'années ça
se fait pas instantanément mais ça se
fait même pas en millions d'années pour
te dire c'est mais après il peut y avoir
des fusions qui sont plus rapides que
d'autres ça dépend vraiment du système
dans un système comprend on peut avoir
aussi des fusions multiples par exemple
dans les annales
alexis il ya plein de gars l'excès qui
fusionne en même temps donc c'est pas
que deux objets dont sa pipe et on fait
plein de configurations différentes
mais du coup magique et sur des
milliards d'années une idée de l'échelle
de temps cet égard donné ça fait
beaucoup
ouais bah après il peut y avoir aussi
des fusions mineurs donc comme je te
disais une voiture qui a rencontré un
papillon et ça ça peut aller aussi plus
vite en termes de nombre d'années mais
bon ça reste quand même des échelles de
temps quand on n'a pas l'habitude quoi
qui sont pas du tout adaptés à l'échelle
de temps humaine ça c'est sûr du coup
les interactions sont essentiellement
gravitationnelle ou alors justement
bahia moi j'ai pris un modèle où en fait
on prend deux composantes donc la
composante theiler donc les étoiles qui
elles sont régies par les lois
gravitationnelle est la composante de
gaz qui lui va être régi par la visite
hydrodynamique donc donc c'est comme un
fluide en fait où il ya une pression
donc qu'il ya donc de reynolds bas comme
comme le l'hydrodynamique classique je
serai pas très bien le dire vite et en
tête le du coup le fluide de gaz va va
forcément avoir un comportement
différent de la composante étoiles et
c'est ce gaz là en particulier moi qui
m'intéressait parce qu en fait plus on
met du gaz
plus on va pouvoir former une galaxie
spirale avec un petit pseudo bull
du coup le gaz va être bien présent dans
les parties centrales plus en or mais
plus il va être présent
ok et du coup c'est ce mécanisme là que
j'ai que j'ai étudié en particulier je
suis perdu un peu dans l'histoire de
bender mais genre tu parles de gaz c'est
ça c'est un gaz
enfin quel point ces danses comme gaz
bah c'est pas hyper dense
bonne question
j'ai pas les sur un tête à prix doux
winx sahara et ça rien à voir avec
l'atmosphère terrestre et j'imagine non
c'est beaucoup moins dense par contre
par contre c'est des éléments chimiques
qu'on connaisse et d'hydrogène de
l'hélium un peu un peu de carbone
il ya aussi des plus fière qu'on met
mais a pris un terme de d'inciter très
bonne question
je me souviens plus et du coup il ya des
choses donc tout à fait des simulations
de fusions de galaxies film a compris
des choses qui t'ont surpris donc ces
simulations
alors oui en fait il ya enfin le
problème c'est qu'on comme le disait on
ne savait pas comment construire des
pseudos bulbes avec des fusions de
galaxies
en fait avant on savait le faire avec un
autre scénario de formation de galaxies
qui est le scénario d'accrétion gad
graduelle de gaz
donc c'est beaucoup plus calme il ya
moins de d'événements cataclysmiques est
juste il ya un effondrement
gravitationnel avec une galaxie qui
apparaît et puis à la crête son gaz de
manière graduelle et ce gaz là peut
arriver dans les parties centrales et
créer les bulbes les pseudos bleus donc
moi en fait ce que j'ai fait c'est
qu'alors avant on croyait que quand on
faisait des fusions de galaxies
on crée on n'arrivait pas à créer de
pseudo bull mais en crée les bulbes
classique donc c'est eric dont je te
parlais avant assez proéminent et en
fait moi j'ai prouvé avec les
simulations que l'on pouvait fabriquer
des pseudos bulbes avec des fusions
majeures donc en mettant beaucoup de gaz
alors mettant beaucoup de gars ça fait
un peu artificiel c'est comme si on
on se disait allez tiens on fait un peu
ce qu'on veut en mai du gaz
mes repères au final quand on regarde
les observations des galaxies lointaines
donc de sézanne là en fait je trouve
qu'elles sont très très riche en gaz est
donc c'est vraiment pas atypique c'est
vraiment pas des valeurs atypiques en
fait donc après il ya eu pas mal du coup
de surprise puisqu'en fait on essayait
de créer des bulbes avec un scénario
qu'on n'avait jamais utilisé pour ça et
et moi j'ai en fait on a vu que dans les
simulations il y avait souvent
l'information d'une barre même dès le
début une fois que la galaxie été formé
après la fusion il y avait directement
une barre qui permettait de dominer le
gaz dans les parties centrales etc ça en
fait qu'ils pouvaient recréer des
nouvelles étoiles et créer ce pseudo
bull donc et donc ça c'était assez
comment dire surprenant parce qu'on
n'avait jamais vu ça enfin disons que on
l'a déjà vu on l'a déjà fait sur un ou
deux objets mais on l'a pas vu de
manière globale comme une tendance sur
plein de simulation différentes qui ont
des petits ont plein de paramètres
différents
j'avais la majorité de métiers mination
qui crée une barre qui tu es ce que la
barre soit détruite après mais en tout
cas pendant une période non négligeable
de la vie de la galaxie la barre était
là et permettait de d'emmener le gaz
depuis le disque jusqu'au partie
centrale et ça c'est wells était pas
comment on fait donc en train de
regarder des images chriqui feuillade
auspices avec une borne pour le presser
de visualiser assez bon ok donc donc
tout ça ça ça permettrait de mieux
expliquer l'apparition de de seebach et
de ces pseudo bulbes ou alors des
fusions de galaxies anciennes alors
anciennes
ou pas forcément enfin oui ancien oui
c'est vrai qu'à nos échelles ça va être
anciens c'est sûr mais mais en fait oui
ça explique la formation de ces pseudo
bulle parce qu'en fait les pseudos bull
sont majoritaires dans l'univers local
donc aujourd'hui enfin dans l'univers
local c'est-à-dire dans l'univers assez
proche de nous c'est toujours à prendre
avec des guillemets parce que on est pas
du tout aux échelle humaine mais disons
que les galaxies à ses proches de nous
ont beaucoup de pseudo bulbe or avant on
se disait qu'on n'arrivait pas enfin on
n'arrivait pas à former des pseudos
bulbes avec des fusions de galaxies
or en fait il ya beaucoup de fusions de
galaxies dans l'univers est le même le
modèle cosmologique qui est communément
admis
il est il se base en fait sur la fusion
des petites structures pour former des
plus grosses donc c'est vraiment le même
carrément la théorie globale de
l'évolution de notre univers qui est
basée sur les fusions et donc il y avait
vraiment un gros souci dans mon domaine
puisque en fait la majorité des pseudos
bulbes n'était pas reproduit par les
fusions or on voit beaucoup de fusion et
c'est sûr que ça qu'on se base pour
expliquer l'univers donc c'était quand
même assez problématique
après je dis pas que j'ai que ma thèse à
tous résolus 1 en prenant en prenant un
modèle avec un certain certains jeux de
paramètres on arrive à le faire et donc
que c'est pas en contradiction que le
fait d'avoir beaucoup de pseudo bull
n'est pas en contradiction avec le
modèle cosmologique admis après ça veut
pas dire que il ya des choses pas
forcément des choses que l'on n'a pas
pris en compte dans nos simu ya force et
ça veut pas dire que tous les pseudos
bulle se forme comme ça aussi mais en
tout cas ça montre qu'il ya un petit
paquet fait en avant c'est à dire que
c'est pas en contradiction mais qu'est
ce qu'il ya un moment tu t'es rendu
compte de ça
faites des simulations elles sont
visuelles ou c'est juste purement
numérique alors récents way sont quand
même visuel parce qu'en fait pour pour
pouvoir identifier les structures dans
mes simulations je suis obligé de
repasser par enfin d'avoir une image en
fait de ces simulations
donc c'est pas exactement les mêmes
images que désolé images de galaxies
qu'on peut voir c'est parce taylor comme
ça mais et puis j'avais quand même très
peu de j'avais pas forcément beaucoup de
particules en fait il ya ça aussi c'est
que la résolution de la simulation joue
peut-être aussi sur les résultats
donc ça c'est toujours la limitation de
ce qu'on prend gg j'avais cinq cent
mille particules en tout j'ai fait
quelques tests avec 2 millions de
particules pour voir si c'était un peu
si c'était différent c'était un peu
différent mais ça restait dans les bars
des rares donc c'était acceptable on va
dire après si on prend 25 ou 30 millions
de particules je garantis pas le
résultat mais mais voilà après donc
voilà après je partais des images et je
faisais la même méthodologie que ce que
je veux que ce que j'ai fait sur mais
sur mes images sur mes vraies images de
galaxies
parce qu'en fait j'ai une partie quand
même une petite partie observationnelles
où j'ai travaillé sur des images de
galaxies locales pour savoir va
concrètement combien de pseudo bulbes
anstett sa faim proportions on avait
dans l'univers local pour me baser sur
quelque chose de concret quoi et donc
j'ai le but c'était vraiment de pouvoir
appliquer la même méthode aux
simulations que celles qu'on applique
aux observations pour avoir quelque
chose d'uniformes donc ce qu'on fait
quand quand on a ces images là eh ben on
décompose toutes les structures qu'on
voit donc on dit mais de telles tel
rayon at-elle rayon cessèrent le bulbe
de tels rien at-elle riant j'ai le
disque alors il ya encore une fois il ya
plusieurs types de disques il ya le
disque interne yeux le disque
il ya le disque et payent à l'eau etc
il ya plusieurs structures aussi dans le
disque moi je m'intéressais plus aux
différents types de structures qui
étaient présents dans le bulbe donc la
partie centrale et tout ça en fait
alors j'ai essayé de l'automatiser avec
des logiciels qui qui vont ajuster en 2d
deux dimensions les structures qui voit
le problème c'est que il ya beaucoup de
dégénérescence il y avait beaucoup de
paramètres ajusté et du coup il ya
plusieurs solutions qui qui sortent et
des fois il va sortir une solution qui
n'est pas forcément à celle qui est
physique humain qui est correct et du
coup à ce moment là il faut quand même
un humain pour pour lui donner des
contraintes et choisir bas jusque là
c'est sûr que c'est le bulbe jusque là
c'est sûr que c'est le disque donc il ya
quand même une partie kiné qui est non
automatisés donc voilà donc c'était
quand même assez fastidieux mais je suis
arrivé est ce que au moment du coup août
et y était dit amela j'obtiens des
pseudos bulle de scénario bas pas
forcément parce qu'en fait avant de
publier un article date a plein de temps
à aller retour autant sur tes données
que sur ton article en lui-même et
jusqu'à avoir les résultats finaux qui
sont publiés tu j'ai pas eu de eureka
sur la dissimulation
parce qu'en fait il faut toujours tout
vérifier et j'ai géré fait je ne sais
pas combien de fois mais simulation dans
cette de simulation avant de savoir
qu'il était juste donc appris ta des
indices c'est à dire que souvent tu vas
retrouver des pseudos bible et cetera
mais tu te rends compte qu'il ya une et
raretés jamais sûr que ce que tu vois
c'est entre guillemets c'est la réalité
donc faut que je refasse des simulations
en ayant corrigé des rares puis après tu
te rends compte d'une autre erreur et
s'est fait à la fin quand un peu plus
que tu as fait 200 simulation tu vois
les résultats étaient dire
ok donc c'est ça mais résultats finaux
et ça que j'ai pu gagner mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas d'un coup en fait t'as pas
les résultats
ben c'était plus progressif et dit petit
à petit a c'est l'art de supermarchés
ouais c'est vraiment du tâtonnement en
fait parce qu'on peut se dire que l'on
pourrait dire oui si je mets les bons
paramètres objets des résultats
directement sauf quoi en fait
yahia c'est plus compliqué que ça il ya
plein de choses
des fois tu crois que tu as bon puis tu
te rends compte qu'en fait tu as des
résultats super bizarre ou qui
correspond pas du tout à ce que tu as
atteint alors soit c'est une découverte
ça c'est que tu t'es complètement
plantée sur un truc souvent effectifs et
vendez et ouais c'est vraiment du
tâtonnement et ça dure pas six mois ça
dure vraiment trois ans donc deux ans tu
assures pas terrible pas facile donc les
paramètres dont tu parles c'est quoi les
parts mais alors il ya plein de
paramètres dans des simulations dans des
gros simulation de ce type déjà bombe à
la fraction de gaz
il ya le rapport de masse entre les deux
progéniteurs entre les galaxies daleux
perry centre c'est-à-dire la distance à
laquelle elles vont se rencontrer à la
vitesse à laquelle elles vont se
rencontrer
tu as les angles en fait les angles des
deux progéniteurs donc elles mêmes et
entre elles je mets ce que j'en oublie
mais tu as la quantité et a forcément la
quantité des toiles la quantité de gaz
que tu mais j'avoue que je me souviens
plus des autres mais enfin tu as dix
mille paramètres et il suffit que qu'il
y en ait un
tu te sois trompé mais c'est tout bête
c'est le tamis telle valeur le talent
valeur et s'est du coup c'est pas
physique parce qu'en fait il ya quand
même des relations physiques entre les
entre les paramètres aussi
donc si tu changes la ja fanchone
l'autre ça c'est pareil quand tu fais
des tests ou quand tu quand tu essayes
de voir en fait là quand tu es c'est ça
quand tu changes
l'un il faut des fois tu fais une simu
tu changes
un paramètre et tu te rends compte que
ça fait des trucs super bizarre et en
fait c'est parce que tu as oublié de
changer celui qui est qui est parallèle
afin qu'ils qui se changent aussi un
autre paramètre qui se changent aussi en
même temps du basset pas physique mais
débattue tu te vois tu met du temps à
voir donc voilà c'est disons qu'il faut
il faut essayer de penser à tout et en
même temps faire des choses qu'ils
soient physiques et ouais c'est pas
c'est pas facile
après on est plusieurs mois je n'étais
pas tout seul sur ma thèse heureusement
tu as toujours ton équipe tu as ton
directeur de thèse je j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec le simulateur aussi de
mon équipe qui lui il fait que ça
j'avais mon corps est adroit aussi donc
en fait c'est à force d'analysé etc
il ya quelqu'un qui va dire ah mais là
ça me paraît bizarre tu es sûr que tu as
bien messieurs où ça ah bah non
les camions de paramètres au total vous
êtes je pourrais te retrouver sa femme
si tu veux tu me souviens plus l'ordre
de grandeur
une vingtaine d'accords et de coût 15
devant pas m lle les uns avec les autres
et du coup web et j'imagine qui a essayé
de trouver une espèce de fins de
distribution des paramètres qui
correspondent à vos paramètres les plus
les plus fréquents univers quelque chose
comme ça ouais c'est ça en fait oui il
ya aussi pardon il ya eu il ya aussi la
masse des galaxies en elle-même par
exemple mais oui en fait tout ce que tu
prends c'est sain c'est reproduire les
galaxies typique observé
de telles périodes de l'univers si tu
prends il ya 12 milliards d'années voilà
il faut essayer d'être physique et
d'être cohérent quoi surtout que moi je
viens d'une juin d'une équipe qui est
pas simulatrice à la base qui est plutôt
observationnelles du coup ils ont
vraiment des yeux d'observateurs quoi il
il essaye de faire coller les simu à ce
qu'ils voient et ça je pense que c'est
un bon ça devienne un bon esprit
critique sur les simulations
parce qu'en fait il ya des fois tu peux
faire des simulations qui sont très très
belle qui sortent des images très jolie
alors que des rires et a pas forcément
la physique qui va avec
donc au moins là dès qu'il voit quelque
chose qui est bizarre dans les images
fin ils vont leur père et où tu t'en vas
leur père est tout de suite parce qu'on
est observateur et à la base
donc moi aussi moi aussi il me dit que
ils m'ont fait travailler sur des images
justement pour que pour que j'ai cet
esprit critique la sueur mais c'est
mieux aussi quoi enfin ça faisait partie
un jeu de la démarche d'avoir les deux
d'avoir une partie observations et une
partie simulation
c'était pas trop des mathématiciens
essayer des mains vers des jeunes en
main s'est passé clairement c'est pas
des modélisateurs théoricien c'est plus
des observateurs ouais ouais
et du coup qu'elles sont un peu les
grandes questions qui restent il y en a
plein du coup les chercheurs sont
contents et peuvent continuer à
travailler
les grandes questions notamment sur des
galaxies lointaines c'est vrai que moi
je t'ai dit que qu'on a pris des
fractions de gaz qui était typique des
galaxies lointaines mais on a encore
beaucoup de questions notamment sur les
petites galaxies puisqu'en fait dans
l'univers primordial
je te doutes qu'il ya forcément plus de
petites galaxies qui ont appris
fusionner entre elles pour former des
plus grosses qu'on voit aujourd'hui mais
par exemple sur les petites galaxies
lointaines
donc elles sont très loin et elles sont
du coup très peu brillante et du coup en
fait on a vraiment du mal à avoir des
observations sur ses galaxy l'a donc
après il ya loin tu n'es lointaine
moi je travaillais plus tôt avec des des
progéniteurs qui était on va dire je
sais pas c est par la notion de redshift
bon on va dire je peux dire que ça parle
mais j'ai déjà but passer ce mauvais cap
après c'est plus que du tort c d imiter
en fait qui permet de réduire les
chiffres mais sinon c'est colossal
on va dire que c'est moi je travaillais
avec des progéniteurs d'oeil à 12
milliards d'années de 15 milliards
d'années on va tient mais je travaille
avec des progéniteurs qui était quand
même déjà assez massif
donc elles sont quand même brillante et
on peut avoir des données sur celle là
même si c'est très clair après ceux qui
travaillent sur les galaxie très très
lointaine donc très primordial et du
coup très petite willow sans vraiment en
galère parce que ils ont ils étudient
des galaxies qui sont très très faible
et est très peu brillante et très faible
en masse donc par exemple ils ont du mal
à savoir de quoi elle était composée au
niveau chimiques et puis leur taille
rien que leur taille et leur composition
en gaz en étoile et c'est donc ce qu'on
utilise généralement pour ces galaxies
là c'est des fois il ya des grosses
explosions en fait dans les galaxies et
donc il ya une explosion des toiles qui
va très brillante et rien que cette
petite faim rien qu'une explosion comme
ça permet des fois de juste de détecter
et c'est à dire de savoir que là il ya
une galaxie à cet endroit là en fait une
fois qu'on a la position parce que sinon
on la voit pas une fois qu'on a sa
position on peut poser
bah enfin mettre notre caméra depuis nos
télescopes pointe et notre télescope
dessus et en fait l'explosion de
l'étoile va générer donc de la lumière
et la lumière va traverser la galaxie et
si on récupère le spectre de cette de
cette explosion
on va pouvoir avoir les éléments
chimiques qui composent la galaxie très
lointaine mais bon tu te doutes que
c'est quand même
enfin il faut être assez réactif
c'est à dire que dès qu'il explose en
bas il ya des satellites maintenant
qu'ils sont dédiés à ça donc tu vois une
explosion ils transmettent les données
au télescope sur terre et puis tous les
télescopes pointe enfin arrête ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire et pointe sur
l'événement qui éphémère en fait parce
que ça dure que maintenant une explosion
alors ça peut durer quelques secondes
enfin la lumière qui est mise peut durer
quelques secondes jusqu'à quelques jours
de trois jours dans les meilleurs yeux
parce que quelques secondes
généralement ces contrats de vider à
revoir mais ouais je pense que
généralement ça reste une journée ou
après il faut que ce soit visible pour
nous pour les télescopes qui sont qui
sont là donc dans les mythes dans telle
ou telle hémisphère femme parce que des
explosions en a quand même assez souvent
sur toutes les galaxies qui a dans
l'univers mais il faut que ce feu qui
soit quand même assez brillant que ce
soit visible pour les télescopes qu'on a
et voilà faut encore que ça rentre dans
nos critères a nommé c'est ça qu'ils
utilisent pour voir les galaxies très
lointaines ayant encore une coup de
questions sur sa après sur des galaxies
g de manière générale il ya encore plein
de choses qu'on comprend pas il ya
notamment dans les simulations ya plein
de trucs qu'on prend pas en compte parce
qu'on ne sait pas les prendre en compte
notamment par exemple les trop noir on
ne sait rien il ya des gens qui modélise
les trous noirs tout seul
les trous noirs supermassifs qui sauf
qu'ils sont au centre des galaxies mais
pour l'instant on a encore du mal à
simuler des fusions de galaxies par
exemple comme ce que j'ai fait en
prenant en compte des
noir supermassif l'instant ça ne
fonctionne pas donc avoir pas mal de
questions en fait des choses qu'on n'a
pas compris
même sur la cinématique des galaxies sur
la forme
l'histoire de formation stellaire des
galaxies tout au long de l'âge de
l'univers
même les différentes morphologies tu
vois moi je travaillais sur les pseudos
bull qui ont des plans de morphologie
différente mais après il ya des genres
faux logique on ne sait pas expliquer
mon plus de galaxy des structures voilà
des tout ce qu'est interactions aux
fusions majeures fusion mineurs et puis
les interactions avec l'environnement
parce qu'en fait les galaxies sont pas
isolés dans l'univers elles sont
distribuées sur des sur des filaments
cosmologique
donc je suis resté a déjà vu les images
de toiles cosmique on appelle sa toile
cosmique
un peu comme une toile d'araignée est
l'égalé de louey
c'est très joli et du coup les galaxies
sont distribués le long de ces filaments
là qui sont des filaments de gaz en fait
et donc il ya du gaz aussi qui vient de
l'extérieur il ya des échanges de gaz et
s'est donc enfin il ya vraiment plein de
deux mécanismes qu'on comprend pas
encore par exemple moi quand j'ai fait
mes fusion de galaxies j'ai pas pris en
compte ces apports et ses exports de gaz
du coup une question par rapport à
l'estimation quand tu prends les effets
gravitationnels utilisent les équations
de newton alors c'est ouais c'est des
cdc du un décor on appelle ça du un
décor c'est à dire ben la gravitation
mais en fait les équations newton c'est
pour un corps qui attire un autre
ces deux corps et là on fait ça mais
avec des milliers des toiles du coup
c'est beaucoup plus complexe et
généralement c'est calculé pas à pas
dans la simulation c'est à dire c'est
pas calculer en amont séquelles julien
en fonction des données qui pas en
fonction de la position de juste celle
d'avant et celle d'après va être
calculée avec jus celle d'à
etc c'est vraiment un graduelle et parce
que quand tu as parlé des trous noirs
deux enfants des trous noirs
ça nécessiterait de la relativité
générale ou oui oui je pense que oui
alors j'avoue que c'est pas ma
spécialité mais mais je pense
qu'effectivement en fait le fait de
prendre en compte les trous noirs
supermassifs au centre des galaxies
quand on fait une fusion ça va forcément
influé sur les trajectoires des étoiles
qui sont au centre donc sur les bulbes
c'est sur quoi je travaille et du cou
enfin ouais ya forcément des équations
liés au propre trou noir est propre à
ces assemat c'est là qu'ils sont énormes
qui sont qui sont obligés d'être mise
dans les aidants le dans le code et ça
pour l'instant je crois qu'on s'est pas
en fait on n'arrive pas à gérer autant
de particules enfin autant des toiles du
un accord avec une énorme masse au
centre qui j'imagine doit s'appuyer sur
la relativité générale du coup mais ça
fait penser aussi à d'autres je vais
tendre entendu un peu parlé des
simulations de 2 du système solaire à
grande échelle oui je vais faire jamais
trop rentrer choix jamais trop étudié le
truc mais j'ai l'impression qu'en fait
ils utilisaient pas mal d'astuces
mathématiques en plus pour engraisser
d'imaginer ben ouais en fait il a dit
oui rien que ça c'est pareil c'est pas
un peu la spécialité mais c'est vrai que
rien que sur le système solaire bâches
des amis qui travaille sur ça sur les
orbites et c'est vraiment pas si simple
en fait parce que il n'ya pas alors là
il n'ya pas des milliers de corps mais
juste avec les huit planètes du système
solaire
plus les athées lite plus les astéroïdes
les petits corps etc
les planètes naines en fait c'est un
système qui est quand même complexe à
signer enfin et ils font des ajustements
justement
pour coller à aux observations et pour
l'observation plus on peut ajuster nos
modèles comme toujours mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas de la gravitation simple
quoi c'est paul biya puis sur les deux
grandes très grande déjà le temps du
cueilleur il commence à avoir des effets
climatiques - exactement
petite différence de conditions
initiales on pourrait avoir des
comportements assez différent ouais
ouais sont des grands dj le format exact
sauf poser une autre question à ce que
tu parlais de détection des explosions
d'étoilés lointaines et tout ça c'est
automatisé valoir le le fait que le
satellite vois un truc et il dit des
télescopes de regarder quelles parties
du sommet à la base ça c'est ses tomates
ise mais depuis seulement quelques
années parce qu'avant on est on ne
savent pas forcément comment faire mais
en tout cas la communauté des ce qui de
ceux qui travaillent sur les galaxies
lointaines et sur ces explosions a émis
on va dire s'est réuni pour trouver un
moyen d'avoir des données parce que
sinon c'était impossible en fait est dû
à tous maintenant que la communauté a
bien poussé d'un sens là on a réussi à
avoir des satellites qui sont dédiés
exclusivement à la détection de ces
phénomènes
on appelle ça les phénomènes transgenres
en fait et qui sont directement liés à
une communauté
enfin la communauté au sol qui reçoit en
fait les mails de bar tu es là tu évites
à détecter telle source à tel endroit
elle est brillante enfin telle magnitude
et c est ce que vous voulez l'observer
et la ji woon est donc la personne qui
est d'astreinte général en chef va
décider si oui ou non ça vaut le coup de
d'observer et dans ce 4e ou la fin le ou
les télescopes qui sont disponibles à ce
moment là et qui permette enfin qui sont
dans la partie visible ou l'objet disait
bon directement l'observent tout arrêter
et ce qu'ils sont en train de faire est
observée enfin les coordonnées qui ont
été transmises mais effectivement il ya
quand même des gens derrière qui sont
obligés de modérer s'est pas totalement
automatique
justement quel pas alerté tous les
télescopes si jamais ça vaut pas le coup
et si jamais c'est trop trop peu
brillant et que de toute manière on
verra rien donc il ya des gens mais qui
sont d'astreinte et qui pendant une
semaine c'est curieux ça faisait ça
tourne et que ça peut être la nuit le
jour tout le temps ces noms-là sparta
des astrophysiciens qui doivent prendre
soir des explosions des rapports récents
que tu as deux satellites qui regardent
le ciel et qui t'en dis oh regardez y
parle dans le ciel c'est exact et ce que
je dis regardez où portail effet il ya
d'autres questions dans toi qui te
fascine sur d'autres aimeraient avoir la
réponse et d'autres encore la réponse
j'avoue que moi je reviens vers la
réponse dans la réponse mais j'aimerais
bien que j'aimerais bien être dans une
époque où on en sait un peu plus sur way
sur vraiment la cartographie de notre
univers observable
et puis way avoir un peu des réponses
sur les interactions entre galaxies
parce que ça c'est vraiment hyper
intéressant et puis bien sûr je pense
comme tout le monde
savoir ben qu'est ce qui se passe dans
les trois mois
là c'est vrai qu'on a on a plein de
nouvelles découvertes qui enfin je sais
pas si tu as suivi un peu mais qui sont
arrivés déjà on a en a réussi à prendre
une image d'un trou noir à l'image de ce
qu'il ya autour plus tôt
et puis il ya eu la découverte sylvain
des ondes gravitationnelles
j'ai ça c'était vraiment énorme c'était
vraiment une confirmation de plus pour
la relativité générale et puis c'est
fascinant de se dire que l'espace temps
enfin la fusion de deux objets très
massif créer des ondes dans l'espace
temps qu'on arrive à mesurer en fait
c'est à dire que notre espace-temps se
déforme
alors c'est bien sûr c'est à des
échelles mêmes fins microscopique même
boire moins mais mais on arrive à le
mesurer ça c'est quand même incroyable
et c'est vrai que j'ai hâte d'en savoir
plus aussi de ce côté là dans les années
qui arrivent
un succès fou en termes de trophées
récemment et ses toiles de choses
s'éclairent alors après le grand grand
grand mystère des trous noirs
c'est vraiment en fait un trou noir
c'est une masqué colossal qui est
regroupé en un point
globalement alors il faut savoir qu'en
mathématiques un point n'a pas de na pas
de mesures afin de na pas de rayons
c'est vraiment c'est ponctuel c'est à
dire que c'est ça n'a pas de rayons donc
c'est pour te dire déjà là la
contradiction intrigue mais qu'on peut
se faire un peu sur des nez dans le
cerveau avec ça et du coup ça donne dans
les équations ça donne du / 0 et donc
des trucs infinie quoi donc une
singularité
donc en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
il ya des chercheurs à ce moment qu'ils
sont en train d essayer d'allier la
relativité générale à la physique
quantique puisque à cet endroit précis
où la masse et toutes regroupées en un
point qu'on pourrait penser que c'est la
physique quantique du cou qui dirige les
lois
mais à des m&a des masses qui sont
colossales et qui normalement
n'apparaissent pas en physique quantique
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils essaient
d'avoir la gravitation quantique je
crois que ça fait si je dis pas de
bêtises et et ça si on y arrive mais je
pense qu'on y arrivera je vois pas trop
comment on peut y arriver ça d'air et je
trouve qu'il explique très bien dans
interstellaire quand dans le film
interstellar quand il vend dans le trou
noir et tout c'est à dire qu'on a pas
assez donné en fait on n'a pas assez
donné pour allier allier les deux
théories mais bon qui sait c'est ce sera
peut-être un jour et des trucs comme la
théorie des cordes gravité quantique à
boucles de ces trucs alors cédé je suis
un petit peu ou non pas trop j'avoue que
je sais vraiment pas ma spécialité mais
mais après ça reste des théories je
pense qu'ils sont très intéressante en
terme fin qui sont très belles
mathématiquement après est-ce qu'elles
ont vraiment enfin je crois
suzie pas de bêtises que de toute
manière c'est des théories qu'on ne
pourra pas vérifié enfin c'est des très
beaux modèles mais que qui sont
pratiquement impossibles à vérifier
en tout cas avec les techniques
actuelles alors là je m'aventure jeu sur
un terrain où je suis vraiment pas
spécialiste donc
donc je pense que je vais m'arrêter là
mais oui mais oui ça reste intéressant
en fait de voir un peu la créativité des
théoriciens parce que c'est des
questions fondamentales cclat
sur une autre question tellement tu as
parlé de cartographie de l'univers
danton quoi part ça c'est parce que tout
est une idée d'où sont les sons les
galaxies alors maintenant en fait on a
commencé à faire justement une
cartographie des galaxies au moins dans
ce qui est à peu près locales et on
s'est rendu compte bien sûr du coup ce
que je te disais c'est qu'elles sont
distribués sur des filaments et en fait
il n'ya pas enfin il n'y a pas d'autres
raisons pour lesquelles elles sont
distribuées comme ça sauf s'il ya de la
matière noire ou alors si les lois de la
gravité
peuvent être modifiées ou c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas bien compris
donc c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
l'aspect matière un mois en fait qui est
hyper intéressant parce qu'on ne sait
pas ce que c'est et ça a été ajoutée de
manière artificielle c'est à dire on
voit un effet on voit un effet
gravitationnel qu'on n'arrive pas à
expliquer avec la matière visible donc
on va rajouter une matière qui qu'on ne
voit pas et qui fêtait les faits mais ça
se trouve les faits qu'on voit il l'est
il est dû à par exemple gravité enfin
des lois de la gravitation qui sont qui
sont pas celles qu'on applique c'est à
dire on peut modifier les lois de la
gravitation pour que ça colle aussi à
nos observations
bon ça c'est un peu toi les fins pas
polémique n'est en discussion et je
crois que c'est pas hyper bien vu par la
communauté scientifique que la théorie
de la gravité modifié pour l'instant on
est fixé sur la matière noire mais bon
c'est comme c'est quand même pas facile
de se dire qu'il ya une matière qu'on
voit pas et qui représentent la majorité
de la matière de l'univers
donc c'est vrai que je pense que de ce
côté là ouais quand je disais
cartographier l'univers c'était vraiment
cartographie c'est à dire savoir où la
matière est distribuée et quel type de
tête de type de matière on parle en fait
donc ça c'est assez fascinant aussi
toutes ces parties là parce que du coup
dans des simulations tu avais de la
matière noire ouais alors moi bah on est
toujours obligé dans le m parce que
sinon ça fait ça marche pas en fait les
galaxies ne peuvent pas être comme elles
sont si on n'est pas de matière noire
donc on a mis la matière noire classique
avec la loi classique fin donc ce
n'était pas notre sujet donc on a mis ce
que tout le monde mais on va dire sans
s'aventurer dans des très farfelue mais
aimer c'est vrai que bon c'est un peu
c'est tout ça c'est très artificielle
enfin ça reste des simulations avec
leurs imitations et tu mets ce qui est
communément admis aujourd'hui ça se
trouve dans un canton se sera totalement
faux en fait ce que j'ai fait dans ma
thèse on le saura que plus tard
c'est une façon de parler volé ce que
j'ai dit en interview et sébastien
carrat tout il ya pas longtemps à ce
même pas lui parler de ces simulations
de lignières du coup sébastien il fait
ses petits univers avec ses petits
divers d'actifs et des petites galaxies
en mettant une certaine dose de matière
noire
prévost petit univers vous jouez
amérique on voit ce que ça donne
est-ce que ça y est oui non peut-être et
du coup tu as aimé ton expérience de
recherche
oui oui alors ça dépend je vais passer
nuances et c'est à dire passer une très
très bonne formation
c'est clair - enfin ça a été ça a
développé beaucoup mon esprit critique
c'est ça t'apprend à être vraiment
persévérant au niveau moral c'est clair
que c'est pas toujours facile parce
qu'en fait quand ils arrivent pas ou que
tu trouves pas de résultat bat des fois
tu te remets en cause toi aussi tu dis
mais je suis pas fait pour ça ou
où je cherche pas dans la bonne
direction et c'est enfin voilà il ya des
hauts et des bas on va dire dans la
thèse après c'est vrai que moi ça je
pense que ça me correspondait pas
totalement d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
j'ai arrêté la recherche mais c'est tout
les tests sont différentes en fait tu
peux pas je peux pas te dire la fête
c'est ça il peut y avoir des points
communs mais ben moi je parlais dans mon
cas c'est vrai que j'étais quand même
assez isolée sur mon projet alors comme
je te disais en gros il y avait au moins
directeur de thèse manque aux encadrants
et puis le simulateur avec qui je
travaillais et c'est tout j'avais enfin
j'avais pas beaucoup de collaborations
et puis c'était pas un travail d'équipé
vraiment c'était un tracé tu es mon
projet où j'ai été guidé par des gens
qui ont plus d'expérience mais c'était
pas c'est un oeil ne faisait pas du
travail pour mater ce choix c'était
vraiment la seule qui faisait du travail
pour ma thèse et puis généralement en
fait est tout seul pendant je travaille
tout seul devant mon ordi pendant des
semaines
et puis après tu vas voir une réunion
d'un coup avec des encadrants et puis tu
vas plus les revoir pendant deux
semaines parce qu'ils sont tous surbooké
donc au final tu te retrouve quand même
beaucoup au bout c'est tout seul devant
mon ordi à faire des trucs assez
technique à patauger dans la semoule à
essayer d'avancer aveuglette on va dire
parce qu'en fait c'est ça c'est que t'as
pas tu ne sais pas ce que tu vas
découvrir c'est le but de la recherche
donc après c'est l'impulsion de son
directeur de thèse de savoir partir dans
la bonne direction mais y'a plein de
fois où on parle dans la mauvaise et et
tout ce que tu as fait pendant trois
mois s'est acheté la poubelle et donc tu
dois recommencer de zéro donc
donc voilà donc moi je pense que ça me
correspond n'est pas totalement parce
que baye avait pas assez de travail
d'équipé et puis c'était assez répétitif
c'est vrai que ça ça dépend sûrement du
sujet du sujet de la thèse mais moi
c'était vraiment analyser des chimies à
l'appel et
et j'ai dû faire 400 ou 500 simulant
toute ma thèse pour avoir à la fin une
tendance tu vas sortir une tendance et
sortir des chiffres et statistiques mais
mais ça restait quand même assez
répétitif
après je pense que si tu travailles dans
sur ce site une thèse par exemple sur
une mission spatiale ou sur des données
je sais pas de robots qui sont sur mars
ou des trucs comme ça tu as peut-être
plus de travail en équipe et est
peut-être plus de battues reçoit t2
année tu adaptes plus d'exaltation je
sais pas je pourrai pas parler pour les
autres types de thèse mais c'est vrai
que moi ma thèse était quand même assez
laborieuse j'ai trouvé très répétitives
et où j'étais assez isolée donc c'était
hyper formateur après été super autonome
c'est clair que tu peux chercher tout
seul et apprendre des choses tout seul
sur tous les domaines en fait parce que
ça va être toujours la même démarche
mais par contre moi au quotidien c'est
vrai que ça ne correspond plus je pense
d'eux d'avoir de faire de la gestion de
projets en équipe et et avoir plus
d'interactions ça peut être difficile
car la recherche pour ce cet aspect du
coup s'il veut revenir en arrière et que
tu pourrais donner un conseil à ton toit
du passé qu'est ce que tu dirais alors
si je devais donner un conseil à un mois
du passé je pense que je lui dirais de
deux moins stressés deux mois c'est vrai
que je m'étais mis une telle pression
que bah c'est sympa quand même été une
partie de plaisir ces dix ans d'études
alors c'était hyper intéressant hyper
formateur mais j'étais très angoissée
parce que je m'étais mis cet objectif là
un principe c'est peut-être moi ma
personnalité aussi un qui fait que ça a
été comme ça mais c'est vrai que je
m'étais divin il fallait que chaque jour
la meilleure ou en tout cas dans les
meilleurs que j'étais meilleure note et
c'est que je fasse toujours plus
du coup c'était hyper stressant en fait
et donc ouais dotés de moins stressé
parce qu'en fait je pense que j'en
aurais fait peut-être un peu moins ou en
tout cas j'aurais été enfin ça serait
passé quand même j'aurais comme eu ma
thèse c'est pas si compétitive que ça
quoi mais c'est vrai que quand tu sais
pas enfin et puis généralement les gens
te disent base soit la meilleure est
comme ça tu mets toutes les chances de
ton côté tu te pose pas la question mais
c'est vrai qu'avec le recul j'ai vu
plein de gens qui n'étaient pas
forcément qu'avait pas forcément dénote
un train entre 17 et 20 et et qui ont
réussi à avoir une thèse et qui sont
très bons dans ce qu'ils font donc enfin
il faut pas non plus là j'étais vraiment
parti
quand j'étais vraiment très stressée
quoi donc voilà je pense que je dirais
ça et puis je lui dirais de aussi
peut-être plus s'écouter
c'est à dire ben quand j'avais besoin de
souffler que j'avais besoin de faire des
coupures et ses bas et des fois je me
forçais à bosser parce que parce que
j'étais stressée qu'il fallait que je
révise mais voilà je sais tu es tu
puisses décompresser en fait parce que
ça valait pas le coup
avec le recul que aujourd'hui je me dis
ça valait pas le coup et même j'étais
stressée aussi sur mon avenir c'est à
dire mais si je suis je fais pas de
thèse ou si j'arrête la recherche qu'est
ce que je vais faire qu'est ce que je
vais devenir
et ça c'est des questions je pense que
tous les jeunes se posent à un moment
donné mais mais moi c'est vrai que je me
disais que voilà après les études
scientifiques
bah on était fait pour la recherche et
pour rien d'autre n'a été formé pour la
recherche et pour rien d'autre
alors qu'en fait les compétences qu'on
développe un thèse est déjà elles sont
légalistes et normes de compétence ou
qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait faire et
qui sont après c'est vraiment on apprend
enfin on est formés à apprendre c'est à
dire qu'on va apprendre
on peut tout apprendre après après une
thèse
parce qu'on a appris des choses que je
pense que peu de gens peuvent comprendre
en fait dans la société et donc tout le
reste nous paraît quand même plus simple
en fait
et on va apprendre même plus vite que
les autres parce que on doit on doit
faire une thèse d'un trois ans et qu'on
doit apprendre tout ce qui se passe dans
notre domaine tout ce qui se fait dans
le domaine en très peu de temps en fait
pour pouvoir créer des nouveaux
résultats
donc c'est une formation qui est quand
même assez assez puissante quoi et je
pense qu'il donne après des très bonnes
compétences pour n'importe quel autre
domaine dans lequel on veut se
reconvertir
quatre chocs et du coup tu fais quoi
depuis ta tête
alors du coup après ma thèse donc
j'avais j'ai très vite pendant ma tête
j'ai très vite a décidé d'arrêter la
recherche je pense au bout d'un an ou
deux ans je savais que je ne continuerai
pas déjà parce qu'il ya très peu de
postes
donc c'est très compétitif l'appareil
pour les postes pour les postes
permanents en france très compétitif et
puis généralement faut partir à
l'étranger après sa thèse et c'est donc
pour partie à l'étranger faut beaucoup
publié faut en gros tu ceux donnés à la
science pendant quelques années quoi
donc c'est beaucoup de sacrifices donc
faut vraiment être motivé parce que
c'est pas sûr d'avoir un poste à la fin
quand même après tous ces sacrifices
dont qu'il entend y en a plein qui le
font et c'est ce serait bien pour pour
la science mais bon moi je me voyais pas
faire ça après après avoir pataugé
points 23 ans
disons que par contre ce que j'ai adoré
dans ma tête c'était toute la partie
enseignement et médiation scientifique
donc je me suis dit que j'allais partir
de par la faim dans cette direction là
que c'était c'était ce que j'ai pris fin
ce que j'écrivais c'était un peu ce qui
me donnait un souffle pendant ma thèse
donc ce qui me faisait respirer et tout
est en fait quand j'étais en deuxième
année de thèse je suis parti moi au
début de troisième année
je suis parti en tant qu'animatrice
scientifique
le maroc donc été un bus de l'astronomie
qui faisait un circuit en fait d'un tour
maroc pour proposer des animations et
des observations il y avait déjà eu le
même concept en fait au sénégal en 2015
et donc qu'il avait été repris par une
doctorante de l'observatoire qui est
marocaine mairie amelia joly qui l'a
fait au maroc et j'ai tellement adoré
mon expérience là-bas j'étais parti pour
le circuit 1 donc la première semaine et
je suis reparti sur les propres moyens
au circuit 3 sur la dernière j'ai
vraiment adoré que je voulais je voulais
retourner pour la faim et des le circuit
1 en fait enfin dès que j étais je
m'étais dit il faut qu'on passe en
france c'est trop génial
alors je savais pas du tout ce que
j'allais faire après ma thèse mais je
m'étais dit c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'on exporte aussi en france
parce que bien sûr il y avait des
besoins au maroc c'est à dire que on est
parti d'un des villages qui était
enclavé où c'était à destination de
populations qui avaient pas forcément
accès à la culture
mais en fait il ya des besoins aussi en
france et les gens enfin c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a plus accès à la culture que
cons et qu'on s'y connaît plus en fait
il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'inscrirait
pas plu à l'astro mais qui enfin c'est
pas par un manque d'intérêt mais c'est
parce qu'en fait ils se disent que c'est
pas pour eux où ils vont pas forcément
faire la démarche est alors qu'ils sont
super intéressé en fait quand vous leur
mettez un télescope devant eux ou un
chercheur ils ont plein de questions
donc je m'étais dit que ce serait super
de le faire en france donc quand je suis
revenu en fait moi j'ai fini ma thèse
mais ça me trottait dans la tête de
faire un speed bus france et donc j'ai
j'en ai parlé un peu autour de moi et
j'ai pu construire une petite équipe de
bain de personnes bénévoles
donc on était un tout 3 docteur en
astrophysique
il ya des années et raphaël et puis une
diplômée en économie sociale et
solidaire
donc ma serre dont quelques uns étaient
plus avait une formation plutôt tout ce
qui était associatif en fait de
coopérative où les choses comme ça et du
coup à nos quatre en fait on a on a
construit l'association spes bis france
et on a lancé le projet donc juste après
ma thèse en fait je crois que j'ai passé
en novembre donc ouais on a en a créé la
sauce en novembre donc c'était vraiment
juste pendant quoi ok ce genre et du
coup voilà on a lancé ce projet là on
est parti sur les routes
donc je on a commencé le projet en
novembre et on est parti en août pour te
donner un peu le père league et donc le
concept c'est vraiment de partir sur les
routes avec soi un bus ou dans le cas du
maroc c'était un container sur un
châssis donc on est parti avec une
caravane aménagée en navette spatiale et
puis tout autour d'eux de ce bus on a
des stands donc sur un peu tous les
thèmes de l'astronomie et avec des
bénévoles qui sont des professionnels du
domaine
donc c'est ça un peu le concept c'est
ces danses et de créer un lien en fait
entre les chercheurs qui sont dans les
labos où les doctorants les ingénieurs
le grand public
et puis les associations d'astronomie
locales qui elles nous aident en fait à
toute la logistique sur place ils ont
aussi pas mal de télescopes généralement
et puis ça permet aux gens au public de
de connaître en fait les associations
qui sont à côté de chez eux donc pour
pouvoir continuer après le passage juste
les illus donc recréer un lien entre
tout ça donc voilà donc je me suis lancé
là dedans j'étais à plein temps en fait
toute l'année dernière pour faire ça
ouais et en parallèle en fait du projet
j'étais inscrite à un programme
étudiants entrepreneurs à l'université
paris-est où j'avais j'étais suivi en
fait j'avais quelques cours par exemple
budgétisation communication voit tout ce
qui peut être utile dans ce genre de
projet et où j'étais suivi par un tuteur
académique et un tuteur professionnels
pour mettre en place enfin m'aider à
mettre en place le projet aussi donc ça
a été une année sombre - 10 mois et
voilà j'étais à plein temps donc je
toucher le chômage
après ma thèse et j'avais le droit au
chômage avec mon programme étudiants
entrepreneurs et puis après donc on est
parti en août après j'ai bail à tous en
fait quand le circuit était un mini
voilà c'est pas terminé pour nous c'est
à dire qu'on a tous les bilans à faire
les bilans financiers les bilans avec
les partenaires le bilan moral envoyait
tout le monde et c'est donc enfin moi
j'en pouvais plus en en plus après
circuit on était claquée et il ya encore
des choses à faire et du coup ça c'est
vrai que ça fatigue logement et a pris
ça en fait je suis parti en tant
qu'animatrice scientifico spacebus
guyane c'est pas nous qui l' organisions
mais c'étaient des gens de
l'observatoire donc alain dorison
dirhams et est à égalité qui était alain
et chercheurs et léa et et doctorante à
l'époque et est donc en fait il ya eu un
lancement je sais pas c'était suivi a eu
un lancement d'un satellite qui est
parti pour aller voir mercure donc comme
qui s'appelle bepi colombo
ok c'était le space bus guyane en gros
il n'y avait pas de bus on était je
peins cinq ou six animateurs et on a
fait beaucoup de classe pour parler de
la mission en fait
et puis parler aussi du système solaire
en même temps
et puis on a fait quelques quelques
emplacements grand public aussi un
marché on est partis bao au musée 2 au
musée du de la base de kourou aussi où
les gens passent donc en fait le but
le concept de space but c'est vraiment
de se mettre en plein milieu du passage
des gens et leur est ce que ça vous
intéresse l'astronomie et on engage une
discussion
c'est pour toucher des gens qui seraient
pas à l'écart et pas forcément fait
l'effort ou d'aller vers des choses
d'astronomie en fait donc voilà donc à
prix bas j'ai fait ça c'était en octobre
on a eu l'assemblée générale de ce pays
ce but c'était début décembre donc
j'avais encore un truc à faire jusqu'à
début décembre
après j'avoue j'ai pris un mois de
vacances c'est bien fait et et en
janvier j'ai commencé à chercher un job
pour parce qu'il faut bien avoir un vrai
salaire armand - et laurie douala
c'était une sacrée aventure tube est ce
que tu connais appelé vacances a
commencé au sénégal c'était quoi le
cloud le premier c'était au sénégal
c'est ça ouais c'était en 2015
le space du sénégal et il me semble que
c'etait s'était pas que sur l'astronomie
donc c'est ça il y avait aussi me semble
c'est gib.a de bêtises la chimie la
physique
enfin c'est un peu un bus des sciences
quoi qui se balader dans le sénégal
donc du coup été organisées par des
sénégalais le directement ouais c'était
organisé par alors enfin je pourrais te
retrouver le nom de la personne qui a
organisé ça mais c'était vraiment des
sénégalais qui en fait ont voulu
transmettre les sciences dans leur pays
d'aller créer un événement spécifique
pour ça et ils ont en fait ils ont
invité des chercheurs de l'observatoire
de paris donc à venir je ne résistez pas
beaucoup hésité
je pense moins de 5 ces personnes nous
enfin voilà ça se compter sur les doigts
d'une main je pense est allé là-bas en
fait et pour pour être animateur
scientifique et c'est vrai que c'est je
pense ça a été une super expérience pour
ceux qui sont partis d'avoir ce contact
là parce qu'il y avait pas mal de
d'observation à faire à ce moment là en
plus donc ça doit manger n'ya en fait je
ne voulais pas je voulais y participer
et quand j'ai demandé enfin j'avais dit
j'avais dit mais je veux y participer
dès qu'il ya un speed be seen égale
prévenez moi et tout parce qu'on avait
enfin c'était dans dans les rouages en
fait j'entendais parler de ça et je
disais mais prévenez moi s'il vous plaît
et en fait quand ils m'ont proposé j'ai
j'avais deux trucs en même temps alors
que d'habitude j'avais vraiment pas
grand chose et et j'étais un peu tout le
temps dans mon bureau et là j'avais une
conférence aux états unis pour présenter
mon travail et il y avait ça qui tombait
en même temps et du coup j'ai dû
privilégier la conférence mais les
prochains services bim et quoi qu'il
arrive et le maran 4ème but est de
pousser sur nos jours ce sera donc le
bus oui c'est souvent alors pour le
maroc c'était environ trois semaines
trois semaines à un mois
pour la france c'était pareil pour le
sénégal je pense que ça devait être à
peu près dans ces eaux là en tout cas au
moins deux semaines trois semaines le
concept c'est vraiment de de parcourir
le pays afin de faire un grand tour est
d'aller voir le plus de personnes
possible
nicker parcours coordonné avec des clubs
d'astronomie locaux legault oui c'est ça
en fait on prend des contacts les des
associations d'astronomie locale pour
avoir des coordinateurs locaux dans ceux
qui veulent bien nous aider
et généralement c'est vrai qu'ils sont
hyper motivés enfin et c'est vraiment
très agréable de bosser avec eux parce
que ils sont super motivés conviennent
et enfin on puisse avoir ce lien là
entre des chercheurs et des amateurs en
fait ouais et du coup c'est vrai qu'ils
ont eu et en plus ils connaissent les
logistiques de leur ville
parce qu'ils organisent souvent des
événements donc c'est ça nous facilite
nous enfin ça nous enlève une charge de
travail qui comme non négligeable parce
que eux s'occupent chacun de leur ville
mais nous si on devait le faire en
s'occupant de entre 15 et 20 villes en
fait d'ailleurs il ya certaines villes
qu'on est obligé de faire parce qu'on
n'a pas de contact local
mais voilà le fait que d'être aidés en
fait par ces associations là c'est vrai
que ça nous aide beaucoup dans
l'organisation que vous étiez dans
quelle ville l'année dernière alors
l'année dernière on a fait la côte
méditerranéenne donc de agde à nice
alors c'était un choix stratégique on va
dire c'est fait pour avoir pas mal de
visibilité là pour la première édition
et puis avoir du beau temps aussi pour
que les observations puisse faire bon
voilà crohn et qu'on est au beau fixe on
va dire mais c'est vrai que c'est sûr
que ça se passe bien qu'en bretagne
voilà mais c'est vrai que le but quand
même le but primordial enfin le but à la
base ce serait d'aller voir les
populations qui sont vraiment isolé de
l'offre culturelle française alors on
avait enfin nous on avait identifié la
diagonale du vide je fasse ça te dit
quelque chose
en france la diagonale en gros 2 2 entre
strasbourg strasbourg et lille et
jusqu'à perpignan en fait y'a vraiment
pas grand chose dans cette diagonale
donc ici c'est à dire qu'il ya pas
beaucoup d'animations n'y a pas beaucoup
de musées généralement les logements
coûte moins cher donc les gens qui
habitent là cumule plusieurs facteurs de
fragilité en fait en plus demain c'est à
dire qu'ils sont dus vont être au niveau
financier ils vont être plus pauvres ils
vont avoir moins accès à l'offre
culturelle française
donc voilà c'est ce genre de zone où on
aimerait bien aller en fait dans le
futur après c'est vrai que pour la
première édition donc c'était 10 pour
pas pour qu'on trouve des financements
et qu'on touche beaucoup de personnes
parce que c'est vrai qu'au final la
diagonale du vide
il ya aussi moins de personnes en terme
de deux chiffres et du coup voilà pour
essayer d'avoir tous au top on était
parti sur la côte méditerranéenne
mais pour mieux pouvoir après partir
dans des zones plus isolées quoi pour
pouvoir lancer en fait l'association
donc là cette année
on part sur le littoral atlantique
donc entre angoulême et sarzeau doha
douzaine de villes je pense si je me
trompe pas et là ça sera un peu plus
dans les terres et je pense qu'on aura
aussi peut-être une population
différente mais c'est intéressant en
fait de voir à chaque fois quel type de
population touche donc on fait des
pompes et des petits questionnaires à la
fin de la fin des activités au public
pour avoir des statistiques mais pour
voilà savoir un peu quel type de
population en touche mais c'est vrai que
le but à la fin ce serait d'aller
partout en france et que tout le monde
puisse faire les skates ging dans la
navette spatiale
ce que tu coules j'avais fait les
statistiques pour les dernières oui
alors l'année dernière pour l'édition
en tout il ya eu onze mille cinq cents
personnes qui ont participé aux
activités
il ya eu pas mal de filles semblent au
final
c'est vrai qu'en sciences enfin ça c'est
un des autres objectifs du pays but
c'est de valoriser la place des femmes
dans les sciences et de montrer voilà
qu'on peut être une femme qu'on peut
être jeune et que et qu'on fait des
sciences ce qu' il n'y a aucun souci et
ne pas se sentir et sur ça et du coup il
me semble si je dis pas de bêtises que
c'était assez égalitaire en fait donc ça
c'était c'était vraiment sympa
il ya vu pas mal de familles c'est vrai
puisque c'est l'été et puis du coup ça
fait une activité pour pour la journée
donc il y avait il y avait pas mal de
familles avec des enfants et tout donc
c'était vraiment sympa c'était plutôt
des touristes ou des locaux alors on
n'avait pas cette question à notre
questionnaire
c'est pour ça qu'on en fait on est en
eux s'est rendu compte qu'on l'avait pas
mise après avoir imprimé donc on s'est
dit pour l'année prochaine on le fera
mais par contre tu as un public assez
jeune enfin c'est à dire des gens fin
des parents à ces jeunes avec des
enfants et mis beaucoup d'enfants ou
d'ados et et je pense enfin moi j'ai
fait tout le mois je pense que c'était
quand même beaucoup de touristes parce
que parce qu'à mon avis il ya enfin il y
avait vraiment beaucoup de monde sur
certaines étapes et je pense que dans
les petites villes où on était ce
n'était pas forcément dès que des locaux
quoi il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
touristes à mon avis donc en proportion
je pense qu'elle est beaucoup de
touristes mais après c'est on va voir
cette année maintenant que conques s'est
améliorée sur le questionnaire du coup
vous proposez quoi comme activité alors
on a pas mal d'activités on a développé
aussi tout le contenu pédagogique en
fait l'année dernière donc je te dis pas
entre la construction de la caravane la
levée tron avant ça le contenu
pédagogique la logistique des bénévoles
et tous on était vraiment c'était
vraiment le régime
mais alors d'animation donc on a les
skins game dans la caravane en navette
spatiale donc vous partez sur mars
et tout ne se passe pas comme prévu
c'est à dire 15 minutes après donc on a
des stands autour de la caravane et on a
une maquette du système solaire à
l'échelle 1 mètre égale 1 1 million de
kilomètres donc ça c'est assez sympa les
gens aiment bien ce que ça permet
vraiment de se rendre compte de la
différence de taille entre les planètes
on a aussi un ballon piqué censé
représenter le soleil qui fait un mètre
de diamètre
ouais donc ça c'est sympa les enfants
aiment bien et puis on a des cubes de
densité qui permettent en fait si c'est
si on prenait un cube de jupiter et un
cube de la terre par exemple
en fait on peut voir la densité entre
les planètes et donc forcément la
planète gazeuse vont être moins dense
que les planètes rocheuses par exemple
donc ça des deux enfants aime bien après
on a on a une activité mythe et sciences
donc c'est pour un peu détruire les on
va dire les mythes ou les croyances
populaires et dire ce que la science
nous dit en fait sur c'est sur ces
questions là oui on a filmé science vu
que peut donner un exemple de deux
mythes que exemple est-ce que les
cheveux poussent plus vite que poussent
plus vite quand il ya pleine lune ou des
choses comme ça qu'est bon on sait pas à
tuer encore à la tâche est-ce que la
paix est ce que la terre est plate et
choix difficiles cela on n'avait pas eu
le temps de la faire et on s'est dit que
c'était un peu c'était un peu quand à
dire que polémique mais là cette année
on s'est dit qu'on allait développer un
peu plus vu qu'on a un peu plus de temps
aussi où là
dans ses prix et je fais un peu plus les
légalistes qu'on n'avait pas appelé
voilà on a aussi filmé science donc là
on décortique un peu tout ce qui est
vrai pas vrai dans les films de science
fiction
on a une animation sur la conquête
spatiale donc un peu toute l'histoire
et puis comment construire une fusée
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme comeau du dans
une fusée de il ya une animation qui est
sympa c'est une animation en fait on
doit reconnaître une météorite parmi des
cailloux terrestre donc bien sûr on vous
explique
enfin on vous donne un mini cours entre
guillemets avant sur les
caractéristiques que doit avoir une
météorite pour soc pour que ce soit il
mettait bien de l'espace et ensuite
c'est à vous de les différencier dans
les différentes
enfin parmi les cailloux qu'on a à la
disposition tu connais la chaîne source
de confort oui la vidéo lécher les
cailloux la samba
ouais c'est ce que j'ai fait ah oui si
bas justement vont parler un peu des
femmes dans la science on accroche des
portraits de femmes scientifiques un peu
partout sur nos stands pour donner des
petits modèles et des dépôts retraits en
fait de deux personnes qu'on connaît pas
forcément une qui ont souvent travaillé
dans l'ombre par exemple
henriette aller vite ou moins elle est
là encore un peu connu mais j'avoue que
la jeunesse donc mais il y en a plein
emploi il ya une quarantaine de
portraits je pense oui bien sûr il ya
marie curie mais encore je te dis des
gens qui sont connus il y en a plein
d'autres convenait pas et qui conte
vrai en fait à la science en astronomie
en particulier parce que vous avez des
des programmes de lecture et ouais les
programmes de la nasa là qu'on voyait
dans le film les figures de l'ombre il
ya aussi bas la première astronaute le
moyenne à plein aux as cooper ou ada
lovelace dans cette liste de
l'informatique mais ouais par exemple
après je crois que j'ai fait si on a
quand même un super super activités
quelques a fait beaucoup de cas eu
beaucoup de succès c'est la réalité
virtuelle ou réalité augmentée donc ça
ça déborde des partenariats qu on fait
aussi mais l'année dernière on avait
fait un partenariat avec la boîte de
bras de la 25e heure donc il ya qui a
fait le film sur thomas pesquet et du
coup on avait des casques 360° avec cinq
minutes cinq minutes de film où on
pouvait on pouvait se mettre à la place
de thomas pesquet dans l' iss et puis se
baladait aussi à prévoir les planètes
des good way c'était vraiment super et
et ça ça a vraiment fait l'unanimité
hélas cette année ça va être plutôt de
la réalité augmentée à voir si le
partenariat avec la 25e heure continue
ou pas ou si nous aussi on s'achète des
casques de réalité virtuelle
parce qu'on aimerait bien avoir aussi
être indépendant choc ça et pouvoir
projeter un peu ce qu'on veut donc ça
sera ce sera aussi pour les futures
éditions mais mais en tout cas il ya on
a déjà commencé à à créer quelque chose
en réalité augmentée en partenariat avec
vincent milieu c'est va qui fait ça et
c'est notamment sur le gîte de l'ouest y
donc le futur télescope spatial
et sur les exoplanètes il me semble si
je ne trompe pas ok ce que tu connais
miro janvier oui enfin je la connais de
nom et de vue jamais parlé mais raphaël
qui est dans notre équipe travaille avec
elle à l'institut d'astrophysique
spatiale donc la connaît bien
il est vrai que je la croise enfin je la
vois beaucoup dans pas mal d'événements
de vulgarisation je crois qu'elle est
assez impliqués généralement on retrouve
un volet 1 personne donc forcément
d'agonie et oui il me semble qu'elle
fait des choses effectivement en réalité
virtuelle
raphaël dois je crois à la contacter
pour qu'on voie ce qu'on peut faire un
simple super top
et puis voilà donc que je crois que j'ai
fait le tour des animations et puis
après on a les télescopes pour faire des
observations du soleil en journée
et puis la lune et des planètes en
soirée comme généralement on est sur des
places centrales des villes en fait on a
quand même pas mal de pollution
lumineuse
mais bon après le but c'est pas de faire
des observations du ciel profond
supercritique
c'est plus d'initier d'initier un peu
les les gens à l'astronomie et c'est
vrai que les planètes sont assez
brillante l'été donc ça marche pas mal
là vous cherchez pas des étoiles des
jeunes étoiles pas des noms des trucs
ouais on va pouvoir montrer des trucs
spécifique ou à des trucs spécifique on
veut juste enfin leur passé le va dire
le virus de l'astronomie mais c'est trop
super fins qu'ils aient vu que rien
qu'en fait rien que de voir la lune ou
jupiter ou saturne dans un télescope de
ses propres yeux
c'est hyper émouvant enfin même pour
nous c'est une expérience quoi du coup
toujours bien pour l'année qui vient
du coup elle pour l'année qui vient ah
oui tu veux dire pour l'édition 2019
ouais alors c'est comme jeter 10 e sera
d'angoulême à sarzeau donc une douzaine
de villes bonjour le même principe c'est
à dire une journée dans chaque ville
donc généralement les animations c'est
de 14h à 23h les associations locales
nous aide pas mal pour les soirées
d'observation et si parce qu'ils ont pas
mal de tes risques
et voilà après il ya une quinzaine de
bénévoles en fait qui partent un peu
comme en colonie de vacances sur moi
donc en parler
les bénévoles tourner d'une semaine à
l'autre parce que c'est vrai que c'est
fatigant ya que le noyau dur qui reste
qu'ils restent tous deux mois mais on
essaie de rafraîchir l'équipe de
bénévoles et et voilà donc c'est des
professionnels du domaine donc soit
chercheurs ingénieurs et doctorants
ça peut être même des étudiants en
master d'astronomie par exemple la
verrière en aviaire ou même on avait
même une
une doctorante en philosophie des
sciences l'année dernière donc c'était
hyper intéressant on a vraiment tous les
tous les domaines de recherche
d'ailleurs oui j'ai oublié une animation
mais il ya une animation sur les
échelles de l'univers dont garde russe
kosmos et là c'est vrai que chacun après
à sa spécialité donc ce qu'est ce qu'ils
sont plutôt planète au ils vont faire
système solaire météorites ou alors ils
vont s'aventurer sur des choses qui
connaissent pas ils vont apprendre aussi
des choses pour faire l'animation donc
c'est super intéressant est généralement
ouais c'est très bonne ambiance
et puis on accueille les gens donc les
skates games et sur inscription
est-ce que ça dure 15 minutes et on peut
pas faire passer tout le monde
généralement dans la journée après comme
en fait un circuit de ville en ville il
ya des fois où la ville depuis vente est
assez proche de celle où on est et donc
s'il ya plus de place ce jour là bas on
peut s'inscrire pour le lendemain ou
dans deux jours pas trop loin quoi
là mais ça dépendra moins du circuit
mais en tout cas
mais là on va commencer bientôt à
communiquer sur le circuit 2019 donc
n'hésitez pas tous un os fibreux sur les
réseaux et si on assite à internet ce
pédibus france.fr donc là on mettra le
trajet final avec les dates les lieux
enfin les places où on est c'est un lot
de convaincant donc normalement ça sera
du 31 juillet au 23 août
quand ses auditeurs dans quelque chose à
faire c'est de faire un peu d'astro cet
été et du coup est ce qui vous manque
que quelque chose vous êtes prêt ou
alors il nous manque ce qui nous manque
toujours dans les projets associatifs
bien sûr c'est l'argent j'ai passé ces
mêmes dans tous les projets tout court
c'est un peu le nerf de la guerre
après en plus c'est vrai qu'on est con
et tous maintenant on est plus à
plaindre n'y a plus personne à plein
temps sur le projet donc on a tous notre
job à côté
et c'est vrai qu'on manque aussi de
temps c'est à dire que le ont fait ça un
peu le soir et le week-end quand on peut
donc donc là cette année un peu de
l'année dernière on a réussi à lever 60
mille euros pour tout le projet parce
qu'il y avait aussi bail avait tout le
matériel a ajouté il y avait la caravane
a construit et c'est là cette année en a
eu
on a eu quelques des pinces matériel
pour compléter mais comme en beaucoup
moins et du coup on a levé environ 20000
euros ce qui est déjà pas mal et qui a
peu plus qu il suffisant pour pouvoir
partir après c'est sûr que tous les ans
il faut redemander les subventions il
faut redemander les aides par ci par là
surtout qu'on n'a pas réussi l'année
dernière à avoir de deux gros sponsors
privés
malgré un bien qu'on ait essayé mais
parce que par exemple au space du maroc
qu'ils ont eu
un gros sponsor qui était une usine
solaire en fait mahzen drogue qui les a
sponsorisé pour le tour et une fois
qu'ils avaient le gros sponsors il ya eu
pas mal de petits qui sont arrivés en
fait aussi une banque je crois d'autres
choses et nous c'est vrai que c'était
beaucoup plus disparates nos sources de
financement à l'année dernière déjà pour
la caravane on a dû faire une campagne
de crowdfunding pour avoir des sous
assez rapidement et donc on a levé 10
mille euros avec la campagne et après on
a eu pas mal de subventions publiques
qui met du temps aussi à arriver qui en
fait généralement le temps faim
généralement on met à peu près un an
pour recevoir sa subvention
donc une fois que ces actes et donc
c'est vrai que ben on était un peu
décalé quoi et et après on a gagné
quelques concours aux six étudiants et
ça aussi ça met un peu de temps à
arriver donc c'est vrai que c'était un
peu dur mais au final tout le projet a
été payée mais là cette année
je crois qu'on a déjà enfin là on
atteint encore quelques subventions mais
on va pouvoir partir on va dire un peu
plus sereinement que l'année dernière
parce que derrière que vous êtes parti
n'était pas trop sur encore ça en fait
c'est mes parents qui ont dû avancer
enfin mes parents quand j'avance et des
sous nous aussi on a mis un peu on est
en un peu moins riche mais on a mis
aussi chacun notre poche point c'est
remboursé après c'est compliqué parce
que pour te dire il ya des subventions
qui sont arrivés là en mars alors que
notre projet était finie en fin août que
c'était hélas on a on a ouvert le
champagne pour une des subventions qu'on
on se disait qu'on allait jamais avoir
quoi donc c'est vrai que c'est pas un
physique tous les jours le monde
associatif mais enfin voila c on a on y
arrive au final mais il faut être assez
tenace le ferry
donc c'est surtout alors j'imagine que
je n'avais pas de problèmes de poids les
bénévoles sont motivés nos bénévoles
sont très motivés oui et c'est vrai que
on à l'ars on les prend que sur une
semaine enfin ça dépend l'année dernière
en impôts on a mis fin on a eu un peu de
mal à à trouver des bénévoles et du coup
il y en a qu'on a appris sur trois
semaines ce qui était énorme hésiter
super fatigué à la fin
donc là on s'est dit qu'on allait
prendre plus que sur une semaine et est
au moins ils seront enfin ils seront pas
vide et d'énergie à la fin de la semaine
mais généralement c'est vrai que pas
comme je te disais en retrouve un peu
toujours les mêmes personnes dans les
dents les dans les événements de
vulgarisation que ce ne soient les
évènements enfin que ce soit les gens
qui sont médiatisés ou où les bénévoles
n'ont point un peu moins connus on va
dire mais c'est vrai que dans les
événements de type spacebus on retrouve
des gens de l'observatoire qui sont
vachement impliqué dans la vulgarisation
aussi de dehors quoi donc donc
généralement ce genre de personne enfin
sont vraiment motivés en fait et ce qui
est web via deux pièces dans les labos
du coup c'était quoi vos partenaires
publics alors que l'année dernière alors
on a eu la région paca qui nous a donné
une subvention de 10000 euros
ouais après on a eu pas mal de fin on a
eu pas mal de sous de nos laboratoires
respectifs en fait parce que ils ont une
partie de leur financement qui peuvent
équipe est dédiée à la vulgarisation
scientifique
donc on a eu peut-être je pense six ou
sept mille euros par nos laboratoires
après on a eu je te dis minéraux de la
campagne de crowdfunding n'a gagné
pareil six ou sept mille euros avec des
concours étudiant et après on fait des
vins aussi on a une petite boutique
durant l'événement sur sur l'événement
spacebus où on vend pas des trucs
d'intro on a des bijoux spatiaux si vous
êtes intéressé c'est parce qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup
après voilà on a on veut un nouveau si
des livres et du coup sûr sur cette
boutique là on se fait une petite marge
et l'année dernière on avait vraiment
beaucoup de choses on avait un peu trop
grand et mais par contre on a vérifié à
avoir 7000 euros de de recettes nettes
en fait donc c'est pareil ça nous a bien
aidés pour payer pour avoir de l'argent
rapidement en fait parce que les
subventions arriver mais comme je te dis
ça met du temps là on avait de l'argent
immédiatement qui permettait de payer
les hôtels et les repas des bénévoles
donc c'était vraiment bien voilà donc
voilà on a vraiment plusieurs sources de
financement par ci par là on va dire et
là cette année c'est un peu pareil
alors cette année on a on a eu de
nouveau de l'argent de nos laboratoires
un peu moins mais ils nous ont quand
même pas mal soutenus et et on a aussi
fait pas mal d'événements alors il ya
pas mal de festivals en fait qui nous
ponctuelles qui nous contactent soit des
festivals de l'astronomie ou de sciences
qui nous demande de venir en fait avec
la caravane aller et on se fait enfin
défrayer sur sûr c'est sur ces festivals
à et on en profite pour faire un trait
un peu de sous pour l'association en
fait donc suivant le nombre de bénévoles
et nombre d'animations qu'on fait quand
qu'on envoie sur place on va faire on va
gagner plus ou moins de sous mais c'est
vrai que ça nous aidera en fait pour
pouvoir faire l'édition
de l'été et puis après on essaye
maintenant de faire payer aussi les
villes elles mêmes enfin les villes dans
lesquelles en passe c'est à dire bas que
qui paie une prestation d'animation pour
une journée deux journées de ce pays de
bus donc l'année dernière il y avait
deux villes qui nous avait payé comme ça
donc c'est que c'est possible
on s'est dit ça du coup cette année on a
essayé au maximum de leur demander enfin
en fait le leur demander au minimum de
nous payer le logement et les repas pour
les baigneurs
ce qui nous fait seulement à payer ce
que quand même énorme
et après s'ils peuvent nous donner une
subvention de 2000 ou 2500 euros pour la
journée
ça c'est un peu plus compliqué
généralement mais c'est rude enfin les
mairies sont quand même assez encline à
nous payer logement et des repas surtout
dans les petites villes en fait on a
remarqué ça dans les grosses villes
s'est de suite plus compliqué parce que
il va y avoir des normes de sécurité il
va y avoir des pleins de strates enfin
plein de l'hiérarchie énorme avant de
pouvoir parler à quelqu'un qui est
décideur pour les animations de la ville
alors qu'en fait pour les petites villes
généralement il ya moins d'animations
donc leur programme est moins chargé et
ils sont plutôt contents en fait d'avoir
des animations qui viennent donc ils
nous accueillent plutôt bien marc
marquez a ralenti les petites villes
ouais y abondent administratif permanent
administratif on peut tout de suite
parlé aussi au maire en fait et est
généralement ils vont nous donner ils
vont être en cloud et des subventions
pour qu'on vienne ou au moins nous nous
loger et nourrir donc c'est vrai que
épuisé super sympa l'ambiance
généralement il ya aussi des
associations locales dans cette petite
ville a donc enfin ça se passe beaucoup
mieux en fait dans l'est dans les
petites villes ou dans les villes
moyennes que dans que dans les grosses
villes
l'année dernière je crois qu'on a il
fait comme grosse ville en avait fait
nice ça avait très compliqué on a fait
on avait fait jouer un peu notre réseau
pour pouvoir venir mais
on avait dû payer deux vigiles sur deux
jours bref c'est c'était moi dire
c'était plus source de dépenses que de
recettes
bon après c'était vraiment la fin du
parcours et on voulait vraiment faire
une grosse bulle sur le trajet mais
après on a fait plutôt dg le moyen le
plus est-ce qu'il ya d'autres choses que
vous pourriez mieux faire pour la
prochaine édition 2010 neuf mais aussi
peut-être pour le futur ah oui il ya
quelque chose que je n'ai pas dit aussi
c'est que cette année on va avoir une
nouveauté dans les animations qu'on
avait pas eu le temps de faire l'année
dernière ça me fait penser à ça parce
que on a des améliorations déjà depuis
l'année dernière il voit là une chargée
de communication
mathilde godel qui s'est mis aussi sur
l'animent
une animation climat enfin parce que ça
c'est un des trois objectifs du space
donc sensibilisés aux problématiques
environnementales et elle tenait à coeur
et aussi de faire une animation sur ça
derrière on avait une exposition sur la
pollution lumineuse donc on m'avait des
panneaux en plein milieu du de l'espace
ps bus avec des petites questions et pas
mal d'infos sur la pollution lumineuse
est là elle est allée un peu plus loin
avec cette animation réchauffement
climatique
donc avec des questions toujours
toujours de manière ludique mais plus
sur ce qu'on peut voir aussi depuis
l'espace les effets du réchauffement et
plus l'espace
donc ça sera pour cette année après on
aimerait bien faire une animation sur
les métiers en astronomie et dans le
spatial donc ça ça serait plutôt pour
les jeunes parce que c'est vrai que
comme je te disais moi quand j'étais
jeune on ne parlait pas trop du métier
d'astrophysiciens j'ai dû me débrouiller
un peu tout seul pour avoir les infos
d'ailleurs dès fois je reçois des mails
de collégiens et de lycéens qui se
posent des questions majeures ont eu un
bon contact et qui me posent des
questions sur tout ça que c'est assez
sympa je réponds toujours
et donc voilà on s'était dit que ce
serait pas mal dutil de faire de faire
de bail est un peu tous les métiers qui
existent parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas
que les métiers de chercheurs et
d'ingénieurs ont mis à tous en fait on a
des métiers dans la communication on a
les juristes on a tous qui administre à
sion enfin c'est énorme en fait c'est
dans les organismes de recherche
c'est comme une entreprise donc c'est
pas parce qu'on ne veut pas tiens ce
qu'on peut pas contribuer au domaine
scientifique d'une manière ou d'une
autre
donc à donner un peu tous et tous ces
aspects là mais là on n'a pas donc lui
le temps et je pense qu'on n'aura pas le
temps pour cette année soit point des
projets m et puis après bac ce qu'on
pouvait faire de mieux c'est vrai que
globalement dans l'équipe on aimerait
bien être un peu plus dispo pour pouvoir
proposer plus d'animation dans l'année
est allé voir plus de personnes c'est
toujours ça c'est ca les vulgariser
l'astronomie auprès de plus de monde que
ce qu'on fait déjà mais mais bon après
on fait notre maximum et puis et puis la
sas elle est super à jeanne donc on a
encore le temps de se développer
on ne sait pas de souci du coup quand tu
vois le futur de la station pensée
continue à grossir
bah oui je pense alors c'est vrai que
moi cette année à la fin de l'édition
2018 quand j'étais en décembre moi j'ai
pris un peu de recul par rapport à ce
pays oui c'est vrai que l'année dernière
j'étais présidente
là maintenant je me suis trésorière jeu
toujours dans le bureau mais je savais
que cette année j'allais avoir moins de
temps pour me consacrer ne serait ce que
pour faire ma reconversion
professionnelle et trouver un job
et après c'est vrai que les bénévoles
nous aide pas mal aussi par exemple sur
les travaux il ya eu des travaux sur la
caravane encore cette année il y en a
qui s'investissent dans le développement
d'animations
même s'ils sont pas dans l'organisation
concrètement ils sont ils sont quand
même des aides précieuses pour pour la
vie de l'association
on a un bénévole qui nous a fait une
maquette du système solaire aussi pour
qu'on soit parce qu'avant prenez celle
de l'observatoire mai mais du coup comme
on a pas mal d'animations c'est vrai
qu'on voulait avoir la nôtre pas
toujours demander à emprunter le
matériel et pu être plus indépendant
donc comme il l'était artistes il a été
artiste il nous a fait la maquette
donc c'est vrai que bat toutes ces
petites z la mine de rien ça nous
aiderait achement en fait aussi et le
panneau futur de l'association c'est
vrai que comme je te disais moi je me
suis un peu moins impliqué cette année
dans l'organisation c'était plus diane
raphaël et maël sur l'organisation
logistique des mairies juste du circuit
de la levée de fonds etc mais mais je
pense qu'on est tous assez motivés pour
que ça continue et puis c'est vrai que
ce serait dommage de de s'arrêter ainsi
bouche si bon chemin j'ai envie de dire
maintenant qu'on a tout le matériel est
que et qu'en fait il ya plus de temps à
autre chose que ça à faire enfin en fait
c'est maintenant la partie la plus
facile donc à voir si tout le monde est
motivé pour repartir sur une année enfin
pour faire ça tous les ans parce qu'en
fait c'est vrai que c'est hyper short
c'est à dire que dès que tu as fini
l'édition précédente
tu pars sur le jeu commence à préparer
l'édition suivante et a pas de pause
parce qu'en fait ça se prépare sur entre
chez moi et 8 mois al avance quoi donc
temps de lever les fonds et d'organiser
la venue dans les mairies avec les
mairies dans les villes donc en fait moi
je te dis j'ai pris une pause donc là je
dirais que je suis je suis assez motivés
pour continuer mais peut-être que eux
qui ont enchaîné les deux ils ont envie
de faire une pause justement et de les
ai passé une année
quitte à faire quitte à rester sur les
événements ponctuels comme je te disais
les festivals qui nous inviter les trucs
comme ça et pas forcément faire un long
circuit l'été prochain coin enfin en
2000 ont peut-être laissé passer ce que
du coup ça fait pas mal d'événements
ponctuels de sucre ouais alors on est
parti yala la first lego league qui nous
a demandé donc c'est une piètre
compétition de lego je crois qu'il ya
des robots et si c'est pour les enfants
donc c'était hyper sympa moi j'étais pas
mais j'ai vu les photos c'était ça avait
l'air vraiment sympa
il ya une ville limeil brévannes qui
nous a contactés pour un il faisait un
événement d'astro et du coup on s'est
inséré avec eux oui il y avait plein de
petits trucs balaïa l'événement star the
past entendu parler c'est un festival
aérospatial qui va se passer justement
dans le parc public de l'observatoire de
meudon
donc sachant que la caravane est stocké
à l'observatoire de meudon ça ne fait
pas loin pour la déplacer l'argent on a
rappelé un pas mal besoin de deux
bénévoles parce qu'on a au moins huit
animations à faire je pense donc ça va
être un gros truc dans tout le parc
ça a l'air d'être un énorme truc que
c'est le 28 et 29 juin d'accord voilà je
pense que j'en oublie mais c'est vrai
que globalement on a eu pas mal de deux
petits événements comme ça assise on a
eu une semaine à à lusignan enfin trois
quatre jours à lusignan c'est pas loin
de poitiers
donc ils sont pas mal aux actifs en as
trop par là bas et il m'avait invité
dernière pour parler d'un des classes et
du coup j'avais parlé de ces fusées ils
étaient vraiment à fond donc je suis
contente qu'ils aient pu je suis pas
allé non plus j'étais je travaillais mai
mais je suis contente qu'ils aient pu
concrétiser ça
ils ont demandé une subvention il me
semble pour nous faire venir
donc oui ce site est vraiment motivé
donc voilà il ya c'est vrai que c'est
sympa parce que ça permet de continuer à
un peu space bus pendant l'année et de
continuer les animations après ces
règles c'est difficile ça peut être
difficile de trouver des bénévoles en
pleine semaine en plein milieu de du
mois de d'avril ou de mars
enfin moi la première parce que ma job à
plein temps c'est vrai que je suis pas
forcément être dispo mais l'été c'est
vrai que c'est quand même plus facile
pour trouver des bénévoles qui veulent
bien partir mais mais bon c'est vrai que
c'est sympa
ouais c'est chouette ya eu l'impression
que du client fait il ya pas mal de
clubs d'astro à travers la france que
c'est line up quand il y en a beaucoup
toi qui connais un petit peu way un
patois ya énormément
ils sont tout ils sont tous regroupés
sur le site de l'association française
d'astronomie
enfin ceux qui ceux qui se déclarent
mais tous je pense et ça permet en fait
de les rassembler sur un même site et de
pouvoir nous les contacts et donc ça
c'est super et d'avoir leurs coordonnées
d'un site web leur siège et serra et
donc il ya un énorme tissu associatif en
france mais met pas qu'un astros c'est
vrai qu'on est quand même les français
je assez actif à côté de nos boulots
associés qui font qu'ils ont quand même
des arts ea et c'est même en astronomie
ou en sciences
c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est vraiment
super mais c'est vrai qu'en en as trop
basse etc des clubs qui se rejoignent je
sais pas une fois par semaine qu'ils
vont faire des observations ensemble qui
vont construire des coupoles balaou
enfin oui lui sont ils sont basés et qui
vont faire des soirées qui vont aussi
échanger sur les nouvelles en astros qui
vont inviter des chercheurs à faire des
conférences et donc c'est vrai que je
pense que les astros en particulier
fascine tout le monde et du coup c'est
un sujet qui est très développée enfin
en associatif quoi j'ai vraiment
accessible à tout le monde pour peu
qu'on ait un petit télescope
on peut faire on peut observer déjà
plein de trucs en fait donc et en
province encore plus vrai qu'il ya moins
de pollution lumineuse donc c'est vrai
que ça on n'a vraiment pas trop de mal à
trouver des gens qui sont hyper motivés
pour nous accueillir et est qui et qui
nous mais qui nous ont précédé les scop
je suis assez impressionné par le nombre
de clubs d'aspach et sur le site et le
dire je suis un peu jaloux aussi parce
que en maths c'est va pas connaissance
alors que pour le coup on va tuer même
pas besoin d'un télescope
c'est clair que c'est plus près mais
c'est vrai que enfin les matches mais ça
j'ai remarqué ça dans mon cursus mais
les maths et même la physique
fondamentale
ça fait peur au gens quand tu leur dis
ça ça leur a fait peur alors qu'en fait
ils sont ils utilisent utilisent les
maths et la physique tous les jours sans
s'en rendre compte
enfin ne serait-ce que quand quand ils
veulent traverser la route et qui voit
une voiture bas ils vont calculer un
truc guillemets dans leur tête si
longtemps ou pas de passer enfin tout ça
c'est de la physique et des matelas même
s'ils font pas des calculs est en fait
ouais c'est des gens quand tu les uns
d'imad physique lisez d'abane c'est pas
pour moi trop compliqué et c'est parce
qu'il ya un blocage je pense en tout cas
en france je sais pas un de pays mais en
tout cas en france je vois un blocage en
maths et même depuis très jeune en fait
et même
et même ça c'est encore pire parce que
c'est
j'en ris en fait c'est à dire que tu vas
voir très très jeune les enfants qui
vont dire que les jeunes
enfin les filles vont dire que c'est pas
pour elle et que constitue leur dit
qu'est ce que tu imagines comme un ou
une astrophysicienne ou enfin imagine tu
leur dis dessine un astrophysicien ou
dessina un oui de mathématiciens sienne
en bat ivo ils vont dessiner un homme
généralement donc pas c'est vraiment une
catastrophe je sais pas comment ça se
fait qu'il ya cette ceinture au niveau
des maths et la physique pour tout le
monde et même et encore plus pour les
filles mais mais justement le fait de
faire de la vulgarisation en astronomie
nous ça nous permet d'avoir ce de
prendre ce sujet comme prétexte entre
guillemets pour faire la physique et de
la science
sans forcément faire d'équations mais
avec les mains mais la ville enfin il a
vulgarisé mais par rapport à un sujet
qui intéresse tout le monde en fait et
qui fascine
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est un bon
point d'entrée pour les sciences en fait
ouais c'est une bonne façon de piéger
genre à faire des kits après avoir comme
l'étoile est belle
il taperait allait les emmener doucement
vers le matin parce que les maths
il ya juste eu pouvoir permet sans que
ces concepts de maths aux phobiques une
phobie des maths soient partants sur la
page wikipedia enfin une page wikipédia
anglophone qui s'appelle l'anxiété des
maths
martin petit
savoir problème et c'est le fait qu'ils
aient pas de des associations locales
pour faire des maths dire les 10 que de
faire des jeux mathématiques mais ce
genre voyez quelques associations qui
travaillent à ça mais c'est absolument
pas aussi développée que le tissu
associatif
on est rendus livrés sur goodbye
donc s'il ya d'autres choses à rajouter
non bah moi de mon corps étaient assis
je voulais dire tu m'avais demandé des
recommandations
je crois de jose à suivre des vidéos de
podcasts de livres etc
si je devais mentionner des choses qui
sont particulièrement sympa à voir ou à
faire c'est les alors y en a plusieurs
il ya pas mal de conférences de
chercheurs en fête dans les bars j'ai
pas si tu as is it est suivi un peu mais
maintenant ça se fait beaucoup
il ya les mardis de l'espace du cnes
par exemple il ya les soirées aussi
space up par exemple the last jeudis
donc là c'est tout dit que les derniers
jeudis du mois
je suis allé une fois mais c'est rigolo
ouais c'est un parent c'est pas de la
vulgarisation et puis discussion
scientifique
c'est sympa après j'aime moi j'avais
personnellement j'adore les livres et
les conférences de roland lehoucq
justement sur science et science fiction
on peut danser un peu inspiré de ce qui
les a fait pour notre animation mais
c'est vrai que ça ça plaît beaucoup et
et il va beaucoup plus loin que nous
c'est à dire que là ils décortiquent des
films entiers sur ce qu'est ce qui est
vrai et ce qui est faux ce qui est
possible physiquement
qu'est ce qu'on peut en déduire et tout
et c'est vraiment
hyper passionnant et puis après bah il
ya pas mal d'acteurs de la vulgarisation
qui sont dans le café des sciences
donc pour ceux qui veulent aller jeter
un coup d'oeil à ya plein de youtube
heures qui sont aussi qui sont dans ce
café des sciences l'a donc qu'ils sont
vraiment un super et et que je suis pas
mal moi sur les sur youtube sur les
réseaux donc
donc voila c'était les recommandations
un peu que j'avais très peu comme kit
société qui lobe du tueur la chaîne
chance folle non mais sinon les autres
débats ya les sound of flandr donc avec
sébastien carrasso qui était en tête
dans ma promo de m2 c'est que oui parce
que j'aime bien il ya six ans étonnante
de david loix prg qui est vraiment super
bon forcément l'incontournable florence
porcel puis après j'ai un ami aussi qui
est dans podcast times donc voilà il ya
pas mal de tu parles de johan masoe
ouais c'est ça a été dans ma promo du
monde il ya la chaîne si l'habit à la
chaîne cinéma mais sci ça c'est vraiment
sympa et en fait je travaille un peu à
l'esprit sorciers les la chaîne youtube
de fred de c'est pas sorcier
donc c'est vraiment super ce qu'ils font
aussi donc je conseille vivement
et après j'avais pas mal si moins de
deux recommandations par rapport au
livre bas notamment les livres j'adore
les livres de d'andré brahic ou hubert
reeves forcément et puis après il ya un
livre qu'on vendait aussi à spacebus
comment fait pipi dans l'espace pierre
françois
et il est vraiment sympa parce qu'en
fait ça demain être lus avec un enfant
mais très intéressant aussi pour les
adultes parce que c'est vraiment des
questions qu'on se pose sur l'espace sur
deux manières logistique mais mais mais
plein d'autres et c'est vraiment bien
expliqué il ya un super beau livre
qu'ils ont sorti là pour pour aller pour
l'anniversaire de avoir marché sur la
lune c'est ils ont marché sur la lune 50
ans déboguer photographique de ghisoni
si je me trompe pas et il est magnifique
il ya des images qu'on voit rarement en
fait qu'on a de toutes les missions en
fait qui ont été sur la lune donc c'est
magnifique magnifique soleil voilà après
il y avait s'il ya une série de bd tu
mourras moins bête de marion montaigne
je pense que c'est assez connus mais
c'est vrai que ça décortiqué aussi
toutes les toutes les séries et les
films de manière scientifique donc c'est
sympa
j'adore le livre tu pourras coupé si je
parle trop piloter et es des femmes qui
ne font que ce qu'elles veulent
donc en fait c'est des portraits de
femmes assez emblématique qui sont allés
au bout de ce qu'elle voulait faire
malgré les obstacles donc il peut y
avoir une rappeuse afghane j'ai pas
forcément que des scientifiques mais
voilà c'est assez sympa de lire ses
petites histoires il s'adonne des
modèles pour tout le monde aussi
non peu féminin et puis j'adore aussi
l'exo conférence d'alexandre astier
donc ça c'est vraiment un truc à
regarder pour ceux qui s'intéressent un
peu à l'astro ses vins nous dans les
dents les chercheurs étant les
astrophysiciens on n'a vraiment pas chez
moi rigoler parce que parce qu'on
comprend tout et que et que c'est
vraiment très très bien fait
mais même ceux qui ceux qui sont pas
dans le domaine je pense que c'est très
bien vulgarisé et ça amène landes est
décédé un bon point d'entrée aussi pour
faire des sciences donc
donc voilà tout ce que j'avais listé
c'est tout et faire que nous devons
avoir tous ceux qui écoutent ses
podcasts pour lie à écouter tout ce que
tu a recommandé au moins c'est qu'elle
sera un message clé que tu aimerais que
les auditeurs obtiennent de ceux de ce
podcast armés sasc les baies soyez
ouvert sur le monde et sur des sciences
choses magnifiques à avoir à découvrir
et à apprendre et est aussi soyez
ouverts aux aux rencontres bas des clés
des chercheurs qui se déplace je pense
que enfin des chercheurs d'ingénieurs ou
autre mais des spécialistes d'un domaine
c'est vrai que c'est toujours
intéressant je pense d'eux de se
déplacer pour aller les voir dans
n'importe quel événement donc soyez
ouverts aux rencontres
super merci beaucoup tablent à terme et
recettes
et puis merci aux éditeurs d'avoir
écouté jusque là et à bientôt
probablement merci à bientôt